ladies and gentlemen
today is april 5th 2021 also
known as 4-5 which will from this day
forth be known as trump day in honor of
the 45th president
fantastic good perfect i deserve my own
day and
we're going to have to make four seven
about me as well because i am running in
2024 i'll have two holidays that's the
fact that means
april 6 will be biden day exactly that's
gonna be the best day someone tweeted at
me they were like in order for it to be
fair then tomorrow has to be biden day
and uh
okay i'll celebrate biden day dude just
speak in gibberish
make say sentences that don't mean
wearing where yeah fall on the stairs
and
and struggle to speak goodness i'm not
sad at this point i
kind of feel bad making fun of them in
like a thousand years people put on
goofy hats and then jump down the stairs
while making strange noises and not
understand the tradition the tradition
of
biden day ladies and gentlemen
um we had news and then we started
making jokes and then we all forgot what
was going on
no we have some some interesting news i
was watching i've been watching the the
chauvin trial
and there's something interesting that
i've noticed because i'm watching this
trial and it's definitely that there's
one one live stream playing but two
different versions of reality
i guess depending on your bias and when
i'm watching this trial i'm very
interested in the defense and the
prosecution i got to say the prosecution
got a bunch of very excellent points
across today
about chauvin whether apparently he
never received training where we've seen
this
this photo of the guy with a knee on his
neck oh that wasn't tr he wasn't trained
in that so they made some interesting
points
but there's always a counter now where
it gets really interesting is how the
media
incessantly just chooses to frame it as
though
derek chauvin is losing and i don't
believe that's the case
i think based on what we've seen so far
acquittal is
likely but that's just my opinion and i
could be wrong i don't know what the
jury is thinking
and i'm seeing a lot of the same stuff
the jury as as many of you are
i could be entirely wrong and i think
it's very very middle of the road it's
50 50. it could go either way
i'm kind of leaning towards acquittal
because a lot of stuff that's come out
for instance
the doctor today who testified said that
george floyd had hypoxia
and then even said when asked that
fentanyl the
main reason it's dangerous is because it
depresses
your respiratory system which causes
hypoxia i thought that was a very
excellent point by the defense
and then the counter i guess is just
well it could have been
choking i suppose but it doesn't seem
like the physical evidence to floyd's
body backs that up so long
we'll get into all this stuff what's
fascinating is how the media changes the
headlines of their stories
to reflect an anti-chauvin narrative
setting it up that he's going to
lose and will be convicted and then when
people keep seeing the news
saying like oh defense says this and
they testify this and you keep hearing
how
awful it is and and how you keep hearing
how it should be chauvin going to jail
and they omit the key evidence that
defends him
well then what do you think people are
going to do when he gets acquitted if he
does
their expectations will be set very high
they'll say something like
i don't understand i read all the news
he should have been convicted based on
the headlines i saw
and then riots will happen so we'll talk
about that we got a couple other stories
too clarence thomas
issues this massive opinion opening the
door to potentially sue
or regulate big tech and section 230. so
we're going to get into this and
as most of you probably realized already
because for for a moment someone was
speaking like trump
jameis from freedom tunes is here i'm
back it is fantastic to be back here
thank you for having me on tim
i'm glad you're here sheamus what's that
who are you oh yeah that's a good
question
so my name's james goggle and i have a
youtube channel called freedom tunes i
make educational cartoons and political
satire
mostly political satire on the freedom
tunes channel these days so go
check that out if you'd like we just
released a pretty funny video about joe
biden we're going to be releasing
another cartoon thursday
we release a video once a week so go
over there and enjoy them
yes you're also very learned in uh
history which is always refreshing
to have you on and thank you i
appreciate about the past
i appreciate that i am you know is that
are you are you making fun of the way
midwesterners sound
no no i'm in westerners too from the
past is this that you should check out
the videos as well because we're from
yeah exactly from the past nobody says
it's like a weird stuff
from chicago no that's the weird thing
yeah my dad's born and raised on the
south side and he he like pronounces the
a less than i do when he says chicago
he's just like chicago
not exactly like that like i can't even
do it oh yeah no the a it's just an
offensive stereotype and that's not
actually how people from the chicago
area sound
yeah okay i apologize yeah yeah hey
everyone i
am ian crossland it is true and uh you
can always follow me in crossland.net
where i do
well i don't know i just do weird scenes
so nobody does try and unify the planet
yeah when tim asked who ian was he's
like wait a minute i don't
i have a i have a broad scheme he ian's
not actually
sometimes he's not actually here he's a
he's a natural projection
yeah oh my goodness we had a dude who
just uh who just joined
the team and he he came here several
times
but ian was never around he was like i'm
convinced that ian's ian's not real i
sleep
during this and i was like well that's
well that's the truth that ian's in
astral projection
he's a hologram hologram he's not really
on the show he's not a real person it's
a it's a vibrating multitude of spheres
that's that's about all i can all i can
say about all right great intro
that sounds all right lydia is also here
what about lydia here in the corner i do
eventually get to myself once you guys
are finished
i was going to say that our new uh
employee has been having a lot of fun
saying that
we are all just figments of ian's
imagination
i like this guy people audience too
there's no studio it's just like a shack
in the woods with ian in it
and he imagines the studio and it just
forms around him pretty cool
all right what about that interesting
movie actually
anyway my friends we we're supposed to
be serious but it's just so hard these
days well
it's probably good that we're joking
around a bit because we're gonna get
real serious with this upcoming news and
the consequences for it before we do go
to timcast.com
become a member get access to exclusive
segments that only members get access to
we had michael malus on the show
uh last was like last friday right yeah
yeah thursday last thursday that's
thursday
yeah julie barowski was on friday but we
did this great uh julian
yeah she's awesome yeah she's great it
was a really good show we we did this
bonus segment with michael mouse became
a full episode we talked about secrets
to success
and advice we had for people and if you
want to hear some advice from the you
know from from michael from me from ian
from lydia
and things that helped us then become a
member of temcast.com help support the
show
in the event that there's a great purge
happening that hits us as it probably
will eventually we'll see
we'll see how it goes we could use your
support also don't forget to like
share subscribe if you're listening to
this on on the podcast like itunes or
whatever leave us a good review give us
five stars that really really does help
everybody else smash that like button
and subscribe we are so close
to 1 million subscribers i want to make
youtube give me that golden plaque
we already have some from other channels
but we should have three of them you're
getting kind of greedy man
i have three already we need four i need
one
are you gonna just split it uh among
everyone well no they they will break it
into the file
they'll issue one for everybody on the
on the show really no joke yeah that's
awesome
so just like make me a host right before
they send it you should make it i mean i
just tell them like here are the people
and it collects money
12 hosts and then they cost them you've
been making so much money for their
platform tim even when they demonetize
you
one golden plaque for free and they have
to pay for the rest but they'll issue
one for team members
and it is real gold right absolutely
yeah solid gold you know
the shipping cost is where they get you
really you might be if you look on imdb
you're probably
listed as a on a producer or something
yeah this shows on imdb everyone i think
everyone goes on and all the guests and
everything
beautiful i don't know who manages that
stuff me neither me neither yeah how
about we talk about the news my friends
sure i mean if you want if that's what
you want to do i thought we could talk
about our days
i was traveling most of the day i'm a
little tired but no that's my feelings
don't matter let's talk about that they
don't
you know what matters facts facts media
earlier today
hey earlier today my friends so i was
listening to
the trial live and there was this really
powerful point
uh between the defense and the er doctor
who was treating george floyd trying to
save his life the defense said
you know long story short like what what
what happened and they're giving
really in-depth detail essentially the
er doctor says that
george floyd died due to hypoxia which
is can you give us the the the science
the medical breakdown of what that means
pretty straightforward hypoxia is just
low oxygen like
hypo is low and oxy has an oxygen there
you go
and he went on to say that there was a
high concentration of carbon dioxide in
the blood
now i think on the surface the average
person hears
well he was suffocated right the knee
was on his neck well what the defense
basically said was
can fentanyl cause hypoxia or a high
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
blood and the doctor said yes
can methamphetamine the doctor said yes
and the defense then said
is one of the reasons that there is such
a warning about fentanyl is that it
depresses the respiratory system and and
this is what shocked me the doctor goes
it's the reason and i went whoa from the
doctor
he didn't just volunteer up but he
didn't say yes or no he volunteered up
like no that's
legit exactly why fentanyl is bad it
causes
hypoxia interesting now it seems like
the doctor still went on to say
he thinks that it was you know he had no
reason to believe it was a drug overdose
in which case the doctor still you know
there's a cross-examination the
prosecution comes in and says
but isn't it possible that having your
knee on someone's neck could result in
hypoxia which causes the heart to stop
the doctor said yes
i still think it's very very fast and
the doctor said it's the reason fentanyl
is so dangerous
and so i went whoa i was like we should
definitely talk about this why google
searched it right
i google searched you know defense
chauvin hypoxia and i see this check
this out
look at this google search you can see i
searched for dr chauvin hypoxia
five hours ago abc news er doc theorizes
lack of oxygen stopped floyd's heart you
can see in these you know the text here
the you know uh the questions whether or
not some drugs can cause hypoxia
you can see right here as well
baltimore's son derek chopin trial your
doctor testifies you scroll down
there's even more george floyd's heart
likely stopped hypoxia
what do you think happens if i click
this story all right
let's open up abc police
let me turn this off the headline's
different kneeling on floyd's neck
violated
policy well that's not what i google
searched i didn't search for
that headline i wanted to know about the
hypoxia
this is where you used to get duck go
well hold on let's go to the baltimore
sun
derek chovin trial er doctor testifies
all right well let's learn about the air
doctor so i can pull up the source
and show everybody derek choventral
kneeling on george floyd's neck
violated our policy well that's not what
i google searched so what's happening is
that the associated press
changed the headline in all their
articles after they were already
published
so for me who's trying to search for
this to show everybody what's going on
we're getting a different story which
changes the framing think about it
if the doctor said hypoxia caused this
and fentanyl
it's like the the main reason fentanyl
is dangerous is that it can lead to
hypoxia
and then i'm like i want to show that to
people because it's a very important
point for the defense
and then all of the headlines change to
say kneeling on the next violated policy
wow well all of a sudden now the
articles that i'm pulling up and would
likely show someone imagine this
imagine i had that story right when i
saw the doctor say this i went
whoa and i shared that story on facebook
or twitter wow
then along comes you know my mom or my
dad or my brother and they're like
what's this that tim
shared and they click it and instead of
getting the story where i'm like this is
important
they get a different story choven violet
policy
i did not share that story so here i am
we're trying to do this show
and i was like we definitely got to talk
about that's a very interesting point
it's not a guarantee that he's you know
chauvin will be acquitted because of
this
i just thought it was interesting to
bring up and to also bring up that very
well like putting a knee on someone's
neck could result in hypoxia
the reason why i think this is important
though is it offers a counterpoint to
the narrative we've all
already heard when i try to pull up the
articles we get something entirely
different
that's creepy manipulation stealth
editing
that that shapes the narrative and
here's my fear
when i'm reading all this news i see a
lot of really really important points in
the defense
notably that there's training materials
they've highlighted a powerpoint showing
a cop
kneeling on someone's neck this stuff
many people have seen
in the trial there was an argument
between the defense and the judge as to
whether or not
this actually mattered because chauvin
did not undergo that specific training
the argument for the defense was if the
cops are all you know doing this and
saying this is an updated policy
then it makes sense that this might you
know exist these things don't don't
appear like
the points from the defense about
hypoxia about drug use
about uh you know what we talked about
the other day what was i i can't
remember
all the details the media always
headlines with
chauvin guilty right so now we have this
we have the police chief testified
that chauvin violated policy but there's
another really crazy story and the media
frames it checks out from forbes
derek chauvin defense shows video clip
to suggest
knelt on george floyd's shoulder not his
neck
that's right and when the police chief
was shown the video get this
the police chief was shown the video and
the defense said
based on this alternate camera angle
from a body camera
would you say that chauvin it appeared
he was kneeling on floyd's shoulder
the police chief said yes
okay shouldn't these things be like look
we
we all know that the narrative has been
chauvin kneeled on floyd's neck
it's it's you know it's bad and he's a
bad cop he was fired for it
when evidence comes out that suggests
the official narrative may be wrong
shouldn't that be the highlight for a
lot of reasons yeah
can humans overcome cognitive dissonance
is a big question
and that's i think really it's our duty
to do that
when we're presented with information
that violates what we thought was real
we really have to let go of what we used
to think was real and look at the new
information
yeah i mean regardless of how you feel
about this case i haven't looked into it
very deeply i haven't done much research
on it so i can't comment one way or the
other but
regardless it's very frightening though
unsurprising that big tech and these
media companies would go through and try
to suppress information that
promotes a narrative that they're not
comfortable with well i don't here's the
creepy thing
i i look at the ap so all these
headlines from all these outlets it's
the same
article it's the associated press and
they're just republishing the ap
i don't think there's anything affairs
necessarily i think there's an inherent
bias a lot of these companies and
they're thinking like
oh okay more information has come out
let's change the headline interesting
they
they initially did run the headline er
doctor suggests hypoxia fentanyl can
cause this
but then they change the headline okay
which fundamentally changes the framing
of the story when people are sharing it
right so here's what's crazy though
forbes i find it particularly
interesting
they say suggests the officer not on the
shoulder what's funny about suggest is
they straight up said he did and the
police chief said yes
look they say top line with limited
evidence put forward so far to bolster
his case
that's an insane thing to write derek
chovin's lead defense attorney eric
nelson on monday
sought to cast doubt for jurors over one
of the most prominent details of george
floyd's death
the length of time the officer had his
knee on the 46 year old man uh black
man's neck
interestingly let me go down nelson
highlighted that while it appeared shove
it had his knee on floyd's neck in the
video recorded by frazier
the knee appeared to be on floyd's
shoulder blade
during the same period in the body
camera footage asking arundando aradando
would you agree that from the
perspective of officer kong's
body camera it appeared officer
chauvin's knee was more on mr floyd's
shoulder blade
yes aerodondo responded though the
prosecution which took the sand
immediately after
was quick to highlight this was one
specific moment at a time when the
ambulance had already arrived
and very shortly before they loaded mr
floyd onto the gurney
we are not looking for definitive proof
of innocence we are looking for
reasonable doubt the burden is on the
state
they need to prove he did it he had the
intent if there is video footage that
suggests
we may be looking at the perspective
wrong and people may have incorrectly
assumed that he was on the neck
that's very important and the police
chief said yes upon looking at the body
camera footage
this is the police chief that fired
these cops
now what's fascinating is forbes framing
once again
is already anti-chauvin they've already
made up their mind he's guilty
and this is just a distraction to
suggest otherwise we all saw it
we already saw the nation and who who
was it chelsea handler
yeah they were like we shouldn't even
have a tribe trials yeah oh well
yeah because the media you know told us
what happened so why would we need to
look into it any further than that
the argument is that well there's video
we saw it happen yeah yeah and that's
fair but that doesn't mean you don't
need a trial like what happens so if
there's no trial how is the person
punished is it not by the justice system
i mean they're saying no trial exactly
why
it highlights the exact reason why we
have trials yeah exactly
exactly video comes out that's shaking
at someone yelling and you see a guy
with a knee on a neck there's so much we
need to know to to prove or convict
someone of murder
murder two requires intent murder murder
two and three require intent
it's manslaughter that doesn't it's just
negligence yeah
so he has indiana's neck okay well now
there's even doubt as to whether he
really had his knee on his neck
because alternate body camera footage
that we didn't see before shows
according to police chief yeah yeah i
have no idea about any of that it's been
so long i remember seeing the video it
looked very much like he was on his neck
but also
i saw this months ago and i can't recall
all of it and it's possible he had it on
his neck and then he took it off his
neck
yeah yeah that changes the whole
narrative right change the whole
narrative
it could it could still be manslaughter
though i think is his point i'm not even
convinced it's gonna be manslaughter
i mean it very well could be there's
there's definitely important points to
bring up like
they are saying that he violated policy
that's that's true
okay kneeling on the neck uh violated
policy minneapolis police chief
testifies it's certainly not part of our
ethics i need to get fired for it
so while the prosecution has the
administration basically throwing
chauvin under the bus like
dude did it there's still good defensive
there's still good points from the
defense and i got to say reasonable
doubt
we're not looking for 100 proof of
innocence we're looking at
maybe floyd died from fentanyl
interesting yeah no that's true all they
do all they really need to do is
establish a reasonable doubt and then he
walks that's why i think he'll be
acquitted
not that they've proven floyd died of
hypoxia
but that the doctor literally said
that's
the reason fentanyl is so dangerous
prince
died from fentanyl overdose no physical
trauma he just
laid there and fell asleep and died yeah
so what happened to hypoxia is that your
breathing slows
so much i remember monitoring people who
had been on drugs and their
respirations would get down to like six
a minute which is insane you're supposed
to be like 16 to 18 per minute
because you're just like you're
basically comatose when you're on that
much medicine there's just
you're completely unaware of anything
and you're not your body's not even able
to
i would say i don't know the specifics
about prince he might have been drunk
too
i'm sure that combo is a killer well for
sure i think you know
i went over a lot of the evidence like
it was it normally my main segment
videos were like a half hour this one
went 35 minutes
five minutes longer than normal like
because i because i went through
the charges second third degree and i
don't know if you saw this uh
sheamus that there was another guy in
the in the vehicle with george floyd
this guy names this guy's name is
maurice lester hall did you hear about
this guy
no no like i said i really that's part
of why i'm reluctant to comment i know
nothing about it
check this out check this out let me
tell you let me tell you james so this
guy
according to george floyd's girlfriend
was selling drugs to george floyd and
her
he didn't really hang out with them all
that often and there they were together
in the vehicle
from that it kind of sounds like he's
just their dealer
this dude maurice lester hall was
supposed to testify for the state as one
of their key witnesses
and right before a day before he files
like an emergency motion
he's pleading the fifth and refusing to
testify you know why i think that
happened
why the judge put murder three back on
the table murder three in minnesota
states that if you sell someone a
substance
and they take it and die you are guilty
of murder
interesting yup so i'm wondering if that
look that alone
i don't know if the ju the jury can take
into account the fact that a dude bailed
and played
you know pleaded the fifth i don't think
it's fair to supposed to right
well i i i wouldn't i would be like dude
plead to the fifth i'm not going to make
assumptions about it
like now externally from a media
standpoint
it certainly feels like the dude got
implicated and then was like
yo i'm out reasonable doubt man uh floyd
said he was hooping
on in the video if you listen to it
which means that you the
term is that you yeah you play
basketball no it means that you put
drugs inside your
butt or your mouth yes yes and um
so maybe he did that and that's why he
overdosed well this is what's
interesting it was one of the questions
asked by the defense
and that is kind of gross but the
defense asked the doctor if he was
familiar with people
you know in in that in that sense
and i i don't think that kind of
questioning actually ended up going
anywhere he like diverted off it right
away
but i have to say the judge said this in
september about floyd that it looked
like he had something in his mouth
there's video that shows it and it many
people have speculated that he was
in the middle of a drug deal the cops
walked up so he threw it in his mouth
and swallowed it
and then he said he was hooping and a
lot of times when the
people will be hooping they'll put in a
plastic baggie and then put it in their
butt or something for like to transport
it you know but i think also you just
put it in your mouth and swallow it
without a bag
and that's also considered hooping but
then you're just taking the drug
yeah that's weird yeah reasonable doubt
man that's all it takes
i know i look at the me i look at the
media and i'm trying to better
understand the story but it's like every
time i pull up a story the headline is
always like
bad for chauvin but there's certainly
like it's
it's almost like you'd imagine the
defense was doing nothing just
literally sitting there getting yelled
at the whole time because the headlines
are always
anti-chauvin this one it was a forbes
article you were just reading says he's
a black
man they're very specific they want to
make sure you know well also i mean
the footage is the footage is really
really bad for chauvin too
why but with him kneeling on his deck i
mean there's a reason the entire country
was immediately against him they saw
like even conservative people were
watching that like all right that's
way too far but there's a powerpoint
presentation brought up by the defense
showing the police were trained to do
that
and they called it the recovery position
and some have pointed out the reason why
you you move your foot off of their back
is because if you're if your weight is
in their back then their chest can't
decompress and decompress interesting so
they'll asphyxiate so how is it that
there's a powerpoint position says it's
they're trained to but the other guy
says he violated training
so that's that was the interesting thing
in the line of questioning where the
judge is basically like
i don't know exactly what the ruling was
but it was an argument over
admissibility for the powerpoint
presentation whereas like chauvin wasn't
in the academy at the time this was
being presented
and the defense was like if they update
their training policies
it's reasonable to suggest that chauvin
had heard this or
was told this or in some way this is
part of what the police do
and it was because an officer said no
one is trained to do that that never
happens
and this is really fascinating to me
that the judge wouldn't allow it because
by all means say chauvin was never
trained this that's an important point
and it's good for the prosecution
absolutely
if shoveling was wrong lock him up throw
away the key but if someone goes on the
stand and says
this violated policy and he wasn't
supposed to do this
that's what that's what they say the the
headline says derek joven violated
policy by doing this
but the the the police academy's got a
photo of someone doing it
so how is it how they could show a cop
doing exactly that and say violet's
policy if they're showing it to people
so
were they showing that were they showing
this to people before or after
shelvin before so before so maybe it's
something that the the um
police force did away with by the time
that was done it was a
couple of years before and perhaps but
interestingly
i think the argument was that the cops
said like no one has been no
has ever been trained to do this or
something to that effect like the the
defense
isn't making things like okay i don't
want to say that everybody
is giving their point of view because
they're trying to win a case
my issue is that when you watch this if
you're a reasonable person you're like
i understand their point i certainly
understand chovin may have violated
policy enacted with neglect which could
be manslaughter certainly not murder
but the defense is giving a defense and
it's reasonable doubt
like i'm sorry man manslaughter is
probably in my opinion the only thing
that could
potentially get him on and i'm not even
sure that's going to happen because
that's
negligence and if they convince the jury
that nine minutes is excessive eight
minutes 45 46 seconds
then definitely yeah and i think if he
does get charged with manslaughter a lot
of people
will be upset that he wasn't charged
with more than that
that's why i think the problem is if the
media keeps taking the headlines
where it's like chauvin violated policy
or
you know chauvin did this shovel did
that defense says this you know
it's always framing it as though you
expect him to lose that's very astute
they're they're grooming people to freak
if he gets
i don't think it's intentional yeah i
think it's just that they think people
are more likely to click
because on the story because the story
is bad for chauvin and people don't like
the guy
we all have our bias because we also the
video we all made our judgments
everybody even conservatives are mad
so then the media is like this is the
headline that will get the most traffic
all of these stories that headline they
do talk about hypoxia
but not in the headline which people
will read and then walk away from what
is this they they wrote a headline and
then when you click it it goes and the
headline's different yeah
and then amazing how did they do that
they originally got the headline from ap
and then the ap changed their headline
yeah all the other ones did too exactly
yep and the imaging hasn't been updated
and so google has the old headline
and if you try and search for that story
to share you get a
different story you should just wrote a
new story that's right they shouldn't
that's right
and be like this article no longer
exists if you click on that so the
important factor here is
someone could share the article where
they're like wow
i didn't realize this it perhaps could
have been hypoxia caused by drugs what
an interesting article
and then every other person sees the
headline derek shoving violated policy
kneeling on the neck and they're like
what are you talking about
so you guys remember like the the gold
and blue dress or whatever
or like oh my goodness yes i do yeah
laurel yeah
they're creating this because someone's
gonna have like a cached version on
their
they're gonna have a cached version from
the article where it's not updated yet
and they're gonna be like it literally
says hypoxia potentially from drug juice
yeah and then the other person's like
are you nuts it says chauvinism kill
them what are you talking about i'm
looking at the article right now oh my
god it's like they're intentionally
making people insane
i don't mean literally i'm just saying
these articles and the way the system is
designed
it's making people hate each other and
go nuts it's a form of negligence at
least
like journalistic negligence definitely
oh yeah so
now i'm just saying i think we're
getting to the point where
you know we'll get close to the end of
the trial and if people only hear these
headlines
about the bad things about chauvin only
hearing from the prosecution
they're going to be like this guy's
going to prison and then they're going
to say
acquitted on all charges and they go how
is that possible i was reading the news
about the trial
it was bad for him oh the system is
corrupt
riots definitely i mean i think we can
agree there that there will probably be
riots
i think i think at this point in in the
in the present epoch you can just always
assume that
every major story is gonna end with
riots doesn't matter that's my
prediction for the future there will be
riots
i don't know what's happening but the
riots will occur as a result chauvin
acquitted
riots rights yeah convicted riots right
yeah right
riots riots because he wasn't charged
with first degree murder another death
penalty
yeah uh chauvin gets uh uh uh the
space-time continuum
rips asunder and then the courtroom and
chauvin gets sucked into an alternate
reality and everybody's
right right absolutely interdimensional
rights right
exactly all across all dimensions there
will be right in contact cool aid guy
burst into the courtroom
no matter what but it's like yes there
will be rides so right now what's
happening is like
a bunch of anti-far in a room and
they're sitting there and
the door is closed and there's like one
antifa and he's looking at his watch and
he's got his hand up
and then they're all like getting
jitters like ready to start and then
it's like okay the news came in
and it's and they just burst the door
yeah
i felt like that was in dc last year
like november there was like a march or
something i went to
and at the end of the night i was down
there and you could see i don't know if
they were antifa whatever a bunch of
people wearing all black just like
standing around we talked about that
yeah
zombies before the before the night
before the blood moon
and npcs in the before the script
activates and they when they storm in to
like you know play the game
you like clip through the wall you see
them all like just waiting waiting it
was so disturbing yeah yeah i'm sure i'm
sitting on ledges and stuff
we brought this up at the time but i'm
sure most people are familiar with video
games so when there's like a boss battle
and like let's say the boss like bursts
through the door and he's like rawr who
has
woken me what's actually happening
outside of
that room is the character is standing
there waiting for a script to activate
to start the vo line
and the graphics so they're just like in
a t-pose or whatever just sitting there
and if you can go outside the walls
you'll see all the npcs just frozen or
in a t-position well it's frightening
because because t-posing builds
testosterone
so if the antifa is keep posing right
now as soon as the yeah
as soon as the orders come down the
fight they're going to be out of their
minds they're going to be stronger than
ever before
that would be a hilarious skit we should
we should do that we should hire a bunch
of antifa people to stand in a tea post
outside outside of a protest just not
saying that anything are moving
await orders not just like just don't
say anything
and then finally when something happens
they all start walking and they go oh
fascism oh it's so bad oh we hate it uh
oh man
people will be like what just happened
i'm like oh the the main character
he entered he just spawned yeah
everybody walks back to the same spot
and then puts in the t-pose again
getting ready for the next uh riot yes
yeah man
i hate to say it but i think it's uh
i hate to say that we're getting
comfortable with the
that there might be riots i'm not
comfortable but i'm accepting of it like
there probably will be riots
that's crazy i've never in my past been
like well if if global riots break out
well whatever it was always like there
shouldn't be riots
is it what's no i'm sorry i don't know
that was my listen listen we're entering
this political cycle where like
we're gonna be old and have kids and
you know it's gonna be like oh it's four
o'clock kids uh everybody come inside
the riots are coming and the news is
like the right will be arriving today at
4
10 a few minutes late and they just like
rampage through town
yeah exactly exactly the riot man you're
the meteorologist yeah it's set well and
it said how many horrible things we've
just become jaded towards like first it
happened with with
public shootings and massacres and and
now it's with becoming the case with
riots
we're we're just there was just do you
see this video where the antifa guy
is trying to climb the chase bank yeah
what
yeah he tried that was rough he hit
can you play that are you gonna play it
uh i'll search for it he hit the ground
and then all of a sudden
he started to bleed i put in air quotes
but no no it's like a
it's black paint but it looks like blood
man yeah i really i don't like
no he was going to vandalize this
building with black paint and he fell
and he landed on his head
everywhere the paint starts dripping out
i was like oh it looks like oil or
something like he's a robot at first and
i mean then this girl's like he's like
this guy comes up and he's like
what happened where did he fall from she
was like he landed on his hip he was
like he fell off from his hip she was
like
he landed nevermind he didn't want to
say he didn't want to tell him so
we have this from andy now andy no
tweets at a far left anti-capitalism
protest today at chase bank in manhattan
a masked protester falls if you're
attempting to climb the building
the black paint he was carrying is
spilled all over the ground so i'm not
going to show the actual
because youtube doesn't want us to but
i'll show you him climbing because
apparently that's okay
and then there's people yelling him get
down he's not that high i'm sorry
he's like eight feet up yeah he's like
eight feet up yeah all right
and then he tries to grab on to the to
the uh
the awning falls down his paint
splatters here's my favorite part
call immediately isn't it funny
you know i thought about this check it
out yeah the guy slammed like why not a
social worker yeah
no no here's what i love but yes yes yes
uh what i love about this is
imagine it's like 1870 and a guy's
climbing the front of a bank
and he's like dude with capitalism and
then he falls and hits
his pelvis you know the people around
him would do but just walk away
yeah call for help they just leave they
like
my hip is broken no one's gonna do
anything
they're gonna they're gonna walk away
from him it's it's amazing that we're in
today's today's day and age and it's so
so pampered
that these these larpers are like i'm
gonna claim the chase man hitting
it was like the chase manhattan security
guard i can't confirm that
that he worked for chase but it was the
same guy looked like a security guard
for the building was like we've called
the ambulance don't worry
it's like the dude was just about to
vandalize your building
the right thing you know what man we see
we're so tolerant
and and accepting of this behavior i i
get it what are we supposed to do we
can't just
leave someone there but i'll tell you
this when i saw that i'm sorry i'm gonna
i'm gonna say it
i laughed a hearty laugh you know why
because i've fallen from higher
and i've watched jake brown fall from
two stories at the x games
slam onto his hip get up and walk out
waving while everyone cheered for him
so like so for those of us aren't
familiar with what happened there that's
it was in the 2007 i think it was or
maybe 2006 x games jake brown's on the
mega ramp it's like a hundred feet high
dropping
then he launches like 70 feet then he
goes up a 20-foot vert wall
he's like 48 feet in the air he loses
control and slams into the deck
his shoes fly like 50 to 100 feet just
crazy
and everyone thought he was dead i
watched it live and we were just like oh
my god
and then he he they walk over to him
they check out his neck and everything
they lift him up and then he he limps
out waving to the crowd
wow this antifa guy falls eight feet and
he's going
oh they're like what's wrong my hip
he's frail okay he's frail nice you need
to drink more milk
yeah yeah well it's there's this weird
thing where people have survived falls
from
extreme heights but then some people
will fall like literally five or six
feet and
they'll sever their spine and die like
it's happened it's really horrible and
scary
um my friend was in the military and he
was telling me about someone in his unit
who was a paratrooper
and his parachute did not open when he
jumped out of the plane and his backup
didn't open
and he landed and he survived he
basically shattered all of his bones
but yeah he survived the fall which is
insane
yeah apparently there's like techniques
you can do i guess they say aim for
trees yeah the way you land
oh yep better than oh man yeah let me
let me let me tell you all story let's
let's talk about some skateboarding see
uh i was like 16 and i was skating at a
skate park and there was this
um we'll just call it a box it was like
it five feet high
five to five feet off the ground and
then from the top of it
there was a gap over another ramp which
about five feet
i spent about an hour i'm 16. i'm trying
to do what's called the backside 180
over this five foot high five foot long
gap to the ground
backside is when you're spinning and you
can't see where you're going because
you're looking behind you
i think i fell like 30 times and every
time i hit the ground i'd slip out or
i'd
you know roll and then finally i landed
rolled away all clean and everyone's
like uh they're all cheering for me
and then literally like a minute after
that some like seven-year-old kid was
jumping up and down and frolicking with
his mom slipped
on the ground in front of the ramp and
broke his ankle oh geez
and that's when i was like man that
weird that's crazy how like i can jump
off this on
purpose for like 30 you know 30 tries
and each time i fall hit the ground i
just bounce and roll away and get up and
i'm like i want to try it again
well like they're just such a strange
thing like they're so
my brothers were both in a car accident
you probably about 10 years ago now
on the highway while they were doing 80
and the car was like completely totaled
and they had their seat belts on and
thank god they survived
there are people who end up like
permanently brain damaged after a
literal fender bender
it's just it's crazy you never know yeah
dude it's legit
yeah some people like will bang their
head just a little bit unlike the window
and then it's just like
causes damage but uh are we are we
basically saying that this antifa guy
has been severely injured and we must
you know
i have no idea maybe he got really hurt
i don't know
did not want ems or anything i was like
that
that vandal deserves to lay there in
pain but that was like a
mean part of me i don't know yeah the
way you want to take care of your
enemies as well like the women i love
your enemies
yeah we you know in in the movie the
patriot with mel gibson
he tends to both sides after the battle
and then the
the british you know because they're
evil and they always will be the red
cards exactly basically you know
burn his house down love you because
they did it i'm kidding about the
president you've evolved well apparently
we know you hate the british apparently
no there's a big controversy i guess
because in that in that movie they
depict the british as like
really brilliant way over the top yeah
and so they like make them nazis
yeah no for real like he kills his kid
yeah he's like you tend it to the
wounded
kill her son yeah jealous is great at
propaganda
it was such american propaganda that
movie good movie yeah i mean
you know american problem no the truth
is the the
the british empire had power and they
were basically
the state and telling the americans who
were like yo leave us alone what to do
and so conflict breaks out
but and anyway i think what are we
talking about i have no idea
treating the wounded oh yeah so actually
i'm conflicted on this too because
there's a difference between like
understanding there's a conflict in a
war
and these people who keep doing this
stuff they don't stop
and what happens is they set fires they
break things they don't get arrested in
fact we render aid to them
yeah and so i understand i would never
let a person just sit there if they were
truly injured i'd
call them you know medical team i'm just
pointing out the the difficulty here and
how do you stop someone
from doing something dumb like trying to
climb chase while they're screaming get
down
and then he gets hurt and we're like who
all saw that coming yeah well that's the
thing i mean you treat them but
they should face the the full
consequences that are due to them
legally like we should be arresting
these people of course
don't let anything yeah but it's the
prosecutors and and i'll tell you this
man we've had a bunch of conversations
in the past couple of weeks where i've
been like tax the rich
not literally but i'm just saying stop
billionaires from influencing politics
and i i get a lot of pushback you know
like uh we got i get pushed back for you
know
jack murphy michael malus and they don't
they didn't agree with me on that one
but my issue is these district attorneys
they're getting put in office through
the money of these ultra wealthy
progressive billionaire types not all of
our progressives i don't agree with any
one of these billionaires just flooding
the zone with money and shutting out
the opinions of the actual people who
live there but when people are just
swept up with hundreds of millions of
dollars in propaganda these da's
get elected we know that you know george
soros for instance it was was donating a
lot to a lot of the district attorneys
that's just a conspiracy theory tim i
don't know why you would ever say it's
also
his name i want everyone to know that i
like having a youtube channel and i
denounced him right now that's horrible
say anything about george soros it's
true well i'll tell you this it was the
it was
the mercers the koch brothers it's
george soros it's bezos
it's mackenzie bezos it is uh tom steyer
michael bloomberg
all of these ultra wealthy people dumped
money into politics
and one of the big things we saw was
that uh i believe
this is really funny like fox news i
think newt gingrich was on it was like
you know george soros's foundation
was helping to get these district
attorneys elected and then
fox was like we don't we don't we don't
say that around here and then people
were like that's a fact
that's so funny apparently you can't
even say the guy's name anyway that's
creepy the
look the point is i don't like the
billionaires the millionaires and the
billionaires
doing this because then listen these
people do dumb things they get arrested
and the newly elected da who's very
progressive goes
you're free to go that's correct no
charges it's crazy
there should be some oversight you can't
name soros if i had only read one
single book in my entire life i might
compare him to voldemort
[Laughter]
he was self-made right george soros
didn't he come from well look like
a lowly the left apparently the only
book they've ever read are harry potter
that's true
the thing all they ever reference are
harry potter and the handmaid's tale
both of which are movies or exist in
visual media so it's like i know you
didn't even read them yeah
literally it's like the movie the only
literature they quote like exists on
television
did you guys ever i don't know
they made a movie with with sting in the
early 80s yeah i saw that one they made
it made for tv it was with william hurt
which is way better yeah the the movie
with the david lynch movie was a little
off
oh yeah you told us to watch it didn't
you not the david well watch it for
weirdness but the made for tv movie is
way better
but the book the book i heard the book
was good yeah that was what i was
talking about
it's basically this kid this
these this king and his son his family
would have to flee the planet and they
go are they leave the planet and they go
to this new planet that's a desert
planet
whether to harvest the spice there's
just like this galactic
trade trade item and um there's like
conflict over the
over the spice the political conflict i
thought there's gonna be something like
an analogous to you know antifa no it's
just such a great book that all these
i guess you're called harry potter's
great doom read dune it is political
maybe there's something to it
these people just don't read books man
well this is my favorite thing i saw
this meme a while ago and it was like
comparing
trump and harry potter instead just like
troll left these it was very funny it
was like favorably comparing trump to
harry potter and people were spreading
it around
i thought that was hilarious so who in
that context who's voldemort
probably hillary probably maybe soros i
don't know i don't know yeah
no come on i'm not into harry potter
what are we talking about like i don't
i love how like at this protest they're
holding up a big benefit of solidarity
and i'm like what what is that what
protest at the one where the guy climbs
the wall and then falls and
and hurts himself oh my gosh they're
like holding a big band it's a
solidarian i'm like do you people like
know what you're talking about
for real protest the banking establishes
a problem but
painting black stuff on their windows
isn't that's going to show them
yeah that won't get the cops to come out
and crack down
no i can just imagine you know the ceo
you know jamie dimon sitting in
i don't know if he still see you or
whatever probably and then he looks he
looks on the tv
he he looks out from the hundredth floor
of whatever building he's in
and he sees tiny little dots and he goes
what are they doing is that
is that black paint on my window what
have i done
and then he goes oh push the button any
hits a button
and the building is electrically charged
and the guy's electrocuted and falls off
the building and everyone just thinks he
slips what happened
oh my god that explains everything
like when when the guy tells the story
about what happened it's very dramatic
he's like and he's all my muscles seized
up at once and his version of it he's
super ripped and he's like
he's like 100 feet in the air and then
jamie dimon punches him in the face
you'll pay for this diamond
planes are flying
all right anyway there are better ways
to protest the banks
keep that in mind guys yeah i've always
maintained at the fed
damaging a window does nothing to
anybody but the people have to clean it
what is this guy
do you guys see this guy suing the
federal reserve have you guys looked
into that i think he's going to win ian
i think he might i think he might have a
chance yeah
he's going to sue them for everything
they have and they're just going to keep
printing and printing and printing and
he's going to be the wealthiest person
who ever lived
did you guys see ryan long's not antifa
window repair
yes that was hysterical that was just
hysterical
so he's they have shirts that say not
antifa window repair
and he's like we we like figured out a
way to maximize profits while we're in
you know protesting
and they have antifa shirts and take
they take them off and it's like not
antifa window repair and he's like
basically we go out organize these
protests
so everyone smashes the windows and then
we're right there to pick up the
business
and then they actually went into bodegas
and like talked to them like we'll fix
your windows if they're you know if they
get smashed out
yeah good stuff good uh good comedy yes
good ryan long comedy he's a genius
all right well uh have we have we talked
about auntie for falling off
falling falling let's talk about the
section
oh yeah yeah the first thing i'm going
to do is i'm going to leave with this
81m.org have you guys seen this have you
heard about this have you seen this
no no 81m 81m.org
tracking the white house youtube channel
oh
yes we were talking about this this is a
great story and it's not
shocking at all i mean it's crazy so
check this out if you go to 81m.org they
say that they're
analyzing the real like to dislike ratio
versus what's displayed on the white
house channel so you'll look right here
check this out
on uh april 5th 14 570 views
the video is titled president biden
delivers remarks on the tradition of
easter at the white house
you can see the official approval rate
according to youtube
is twelve point five eight percent it's
got one thousand five hundred ninety
nine dislikes
the real approval rate is only four
point seven six percent
because it has four 4 606 dislikes
this is every single video you can see
that they're deleting dislikes
not nearly enough okay in this one it's
not very it's not much different
some of them are fairly dramatic like it
says a thousand dislikes and there's
four thousand
this one's got twenty thousand dislikes
and youtube claims it only a seven
thousand
now when i first saw this i thought to
myself how do i know this is true yeah
exactly maybe they're just lying
yeah they could be lying could just be
liars could be liars dirty that's the
story
that's but they also include an
additional metric to compare using the
same data
at the end they say trust me bro yeah
i'm pretty sure they're telling the
truth
and come on man come on man come on man
i'm like well i don't know
okay he's got a phone that sounds they
track pewdiepie
when you look at pewdiepie's like to
dislike ratio it's almost identical
across the board there are some
disparities
but that's because youtube does
legitimately get rid of spam dislikes
from you know bot farms and things like
that
pewdiepie is overwhelmingly no his
numbers are accurate
so when you look at a massive channel
like his then you look at the white
house
it's very strange now again i'll say it
it's possible that people behind eight
behind
81m are just like giving us bunk numbers
and then claiming
yeah maybe they're just lying but uh we
know for a fact that youtube has already
stated in the past they do remove likes
from the white house
uh youtube channel dislikes sorry and
they announced that
they're uh they announced that they may
get rid of the dislike feature i heard
about this for people's health
i hope so because it's bad for my health
when i get a dislike on one of my videos
i wish youtube would come here and
delete some of those but you can still
see them it's just other people can't oh
oh that's not good that's not going to
help my health what does that do didn't
they change it to say not for me
instead of a down vote i did say and
you're like this this video kind of
video is not for me and then the
algorithm
tries to feed you less videos like that
i thought i saw a screenshot of a
stephen crowder video that said not for
me
instead of dislike huh i never disliked
since 2007 i kind of made like a
a personal choice to never do that to
someone i either like it or not i
don't like it i don't say anything i
actually think they should get rid of uh
dislikes really is that likes and
dislikes dislikes
absolutely do hurt channels
they make sure that other people can't
see the content so what happens is
because crowder brought this up
that they'll put out a video where it's
like joe biden says you know x
and people will go i can't believe joe
biden said that dislike
and then he's like no don't dislike us
just like we agree with you like like
what we're saying
maybe it's possible to adjust the
algorithm so that disliking the video
doesn't result in fewer people viewing
it but
the audience is still able to know what
the general consensus on the video is
yeah you can have like facebook has
little emojis so you can have the angry
emoji yeah the heart emoji the thumbs up
emoji
make it more complicated and they kind
of show like did you did it make you
angry did it make you happy did it make
you laugh
so they could use that algorithm i've
got a really good idea i think this is
the future for youtube
they have five stars and you can give
the video a ranking
at the beginning or five stars and each
video will be somewhere along the
spectrum
why didn't anyone ever try anyone ever
do this yeah it would have been great
they should have been doing that since
the beginning
yeah yeah like right when they started
they should have had that system like
before they
before genius yeah yeah when did that
change why did they get rid of that
idea honestly i do think like a like
dislike thing is more accurate than
um a star system though because someone
could be like
i like this but like what someone
considers four or five star content is
gonna vary wildly between people two
people can like something equally as
much but one person's like this is five
stars and the other person's like three
and a half
yeah i saw a yelp review once where it
was like the restaurant got through a
three star rating out of five from
someone and they were like this is one
of the best restaurants i've ever been
to
absolutely great three out of five and
then the owner was like
would you mind giving us more stars if
you really liked it that much but it's
because the person thought three out of
five was like
really good four was like wow and five
was too perfect to exist
so possible i found i was on a trip and
i booked my
own hotel unfortunately without reading
the reviews and
then when i got there i was like this
place is a little sketchy why don't i
check out the reviews
so i went to the reviews and it was so
horrifically bad there
i was like i'm gonna go i'm just gonna
look at the worst first just to see if
this place is dangerous
it was very danger one of the reviews
was like someone was killed here the
night i was staying here
the next day i'm not kidding the next
day someone was shot in the parking lot
i was like okay
and then one of one of the reviews said
it was like listing all these things
that were wrong with the room and it was
like and i found a crack pipe under the
sink
free crack pipe yes
i was fine with the mint on the pillow
but apparently a crack pipe under the
sink is
is the new thing um and the response
from the hotel was
thank you for staying at blanken
i was crying dude i have to send the
screenshots to you because i was like at
this hotel and i was horrified but i was
also laughing really hard at these
reviews i was like
i have to leave like right now this was
in uh this was in georgia
wow yeah bad neighborhood yeah it was it
was in a bad part of town
i should have rather because here's the
thing i looked at the reviews well
here's the thing i
so foolish that i booked it very quickly
because i was in kind of a rush mistake
but it said on the website's page most
people who come here
return later so it's like oh it must be
a nice place well it turns out people
who like go to hotels to do like drug
dealers
nefarious things will like go to the
same hotel a bunch of times this place
worked i like
come back sorting reviews by likes or
sorting them by dislikes so you can see
like all the dislikes first i also like
sorting by recent
so you can be like what happened
yesterday and the nice thing about steam
things like someone gets killed at the
hotel
two days in a row once and all of a
sudden people don't like this place
forever a lot bigger
than three years ago oh steam lets you
see how many hours someone has played a
video game
before they rate it so i kind of get
some perspective so if you knew more
about the person that was giving the
rating you might be able to tell
but then i mean that's more of a complex
algorithm well it's funny because then i
was searching for other hotels
and i found this place and i was like
i'm gonna look at the negative reviews
first just to see and the worst review
was like
the attendant was very rude to me okay
i'm staying here this is great
the the main issue with like the youtube
dislike thing is that
first and foremost the white house is an
official channel
that produces content not as a career
but because they're the white house so
they put out updates so everyone's met
jill biden at the end of his press
conference i'd be like
smash that like button he should be
saying that
like share and subscribe to the channel
thanks for watching
youtube press the like button
could you imagine if he's at a press
conference again and he's talking to the
press corps and he's like
now for all you journalists uh you know
sitting in here you know
we're on youtube so i'm gonna give a
shout out to everybody smash that like
button
don't forget to hit that notification
bell and subscribe we're really close to
breaking one million subscribers so come
on man become a subscriber
holding up his play button you know
jimmy kimmel
kimmel does it for the for his show so
maybe they should start yeah at the end
there's like an insert clip where he's
like thanks for watching our youtube
channel
just pretty much be sure to they should
i'm like all right i admire the hustle
and i've been in his position so i get
it
it's like plugging the federal
government's now running on patreon
they're like trying to get
it like all right it's got 328.2 million
patrons
no dude it's like half and it's like
it's like if you if you make this much
money you must subscribe for this year
to make this much money
and it was like and then in big bold
letters if you don't subscribe will come
and arrest you at gunpoint oh my god
that's how patreon should work right
so so listen here's the issue i have
with the dislike button
let's say somebody likes political
commentary and they like subject matter
about
whatever when they give a dislike they
actually like this kind of content yes
they actually like this subject
but they disagree with some something in
it maybe it's the opinion of the person
in an article
maybe it's the opinion of the host but
they do typically enjoy this kind of
content
the dislike in that regard doesn't work
because then it results in fewer people
seeing content they would actually enjoy
so ultimately what i'm saying is if i
make a video where i'm like
i think the government should bring back
government cheese or whatever
yeah people are going to be like bad
opinion x and then what they're really
what youtube hears is not i dislike this
opinion youtube hears this video is a
bad video
so then there may be people who actually
agree with that opinion and they won't
be served the content
youtube is effectively creating
political silos
where they force people into one or the
other bubble because if you capture a
liberal audience and you say
liberal opinion all the liberals give
you a thumbs up
so then youtube's like share with more
people yeah if you say conservative
opinion and
then and liberals give it a thumbs down
they stop showing it to anybody
then what happens is these people are
forced to choose whichever bubble that
youtube sorts them to it's almost like
you ever see a thing where they have the
conveyor belt with all the baby chickens
on it and then they're like picking up
and looking at them and throwing the
mails into the meat grinder yes
yes basically it's basically like how it
feels getting a dislike
every single one i'm like that's not
that's not what i mean what i mean is
you start a new channel right start a
brand new channel and say
my opinion on immigration whichever
person
that youtube randomly suggests that
video to assuming they do
if their opinion is liberal and they
give you a thumbs up then youtube's
gonna start growing your channel
if they send it to a conservative and
your opinion is liberal your channel
your channel is crushed but
in addition to that like you said you'll
you'll make a video you'll say these
people got murdered and tortured and the
person will be like thank you
so much for making this video and
telling me about it that's horrible that
they got murdered thumbs down
exactly that's awesome because it's
important for people to remember that
that the like and dislike button is not
there for you to assess whether you're
happy with what's being reported on it's
there to bully
creators with bad opinions absolutely
yeah what we have today
or just ugly ones yeah like me yeah
exactly every time i'm on the dislike
ratio you guys just get ratio super high
i was like why is this ugly
exactly did you know i need a haircut
battery they look you should grow it out
you afro that thing
all the time you know it's built for it
what what really bothers me the most
though
is that people aren't smashing the like
button for this hand smashing
smash that like button we're almost at a
million subscribers
we're gonna get the the plaques but not
even for the plaque i want the plaque
guys if we don't get if we don't get how
many how many likes do you get on
average
we get like 12 no if we don't get 15
000 likes i'm deleting freedom tunes oh
right now
all tomatoes smash that like button well
no
this this resulted in a genre of videos
that were literally just
smashing the like button videos where it
was really funny there'd be like a guy
and he'd be like hey everybody what's
going on we're going to smash that like
button the camera like zooms in on his
face back and forth there's like
explosions
and it's like five million likes and it
worked because
youtube would prop those videos up dude
so then people just started doing that
that's that's it i love that i mean
people will always find a way to mess
with the rules everyone's always trying
to get away with something at all times
yeah sometimes you'll be like and go
ahead and smash that and they'll have
like low energy but like you gotta like
it's more
like the build up like you can say tap
that like button but if you say it with
like
vehemence you know then it gets people
to tap it dude that like they don't have
the energy then that happens
sometimes because like there are some
videos i end up having to pull an
all-nighter in order to finish
and then i don't record the bumper until
right before i upload so the video is
like really high energy and crazy and
then i'm like
guys please like and hit the like button
if you can't yeah exactly and then i'm
like stumbling over my words i literally
become joe biden when i don't have
enough sleep
you know the button the thing maybe they
should get rid or alter
up thumbs up to say like show me more of
this because on facebook that's what it
does
would you like to know more button yeah
click here if you'd like to know more at
the end would you like to there
shouldn't be a like or dislike once the
video ends
it should go would you like to know more
and it just appeared and you can click
it
that's it with facebook would you like
to know more about what the specific
video
from this from this person
i didn't realize i'll go down the list
and i'll i'll see
things from people that i like following
and i don't even care what they
put but i'll just like it because i want
to see more from that person so i've
broken the out i've seen passed through
the algorithm
can we get 3 000 likes for ian breaking
the algorithm like i'm looking past it i
like it
absolutely so apparently if on facebook
you post
that you have a have a kid and got
married it'll appear on the top of
all of your friends feeds and so what
people started doing for a while is
they'd post like
just got married and had a had a new
child so excited
anyway none of that's true i want to let
you know that i'm having a barbecue in
my house
people are doing that because the
algorithm found out that
people interacted the most with posts
about marriage and having kids yeah and
everyone's like love it
and they're all commenting and thumbs up
so they get boosted
and then the algorithm makes no sense
shameful tim
i know that's fraud well we're talking
about uh
social media manipulation and i think
this should segue us into our our next
really major story oh yeah clarence
thomas blasts
section 230 wants common carrier rules
for twitter
thomas claims twitter's right to cut off
speech raises first amendment problem
this is an amazing story do you guys
remember when trump got sued for
blocking people
yeah what vaguely no there was here's
the thing
probably i'm i'm not gonna say i didn't
pay attention to it maybe i did but
there were so many trump stories that
it's like they've all just kind of
they're gone now they're all out of my
head they just got washed right out
as soon as he left office i was like
that's it don't need to remember any of
this
like dumbledore
i'm gonna get a generational spirit if
you could talk about harry potter about
me i can't
okay so trump got sued and this court
ruled trump can't block people
and it was like one of the stupidest
rulings to a lot of people are like
that's dumb
because twitter is a private business
and how could it be a public forum
here's the ruling trump tweets it
creates a public forum where people can
reply
so if trump bans them it's violating
their first amendment right
so we can't do that then all people were
like but twitter's a private company and
twitter can
remove that yeah and twitter did started
putting restrictions so how can you call
it a public forum created
when a private company has a right to
remove this the way i viewed it was like
imagine donald trump holds and holds an
event
open to the public but hires a private
security contractor
so what the private security company can
kick people out and viola
protesters show up oh but it's a private
security company you know they're the
ones running this event
and control things they have the
authority to remove people so it's not a
violation of your first amendment rights
if you're protesting the president and a
private company removes you so the
courts ruled
trump can't remove you but a private
company can yeah makes no sense
so it actually got upheld on appeal then
it made its way to the supreme court
where they dismissed it and vacated the
ruling congratulations if you're a
politician like aoc
you can now block people again because
she was also implicated in this because
she was blocking people
here's what gets crazy though the whole
thing's backfiring the left
wanted the regulation and with this
ruling clarence thomas issued this
massive opinion i mean massive in terms
of the like
the impact it may end up having he
issued his opinion which will have a
massive impact
in my opinion where he said that how is
it that a private company like twitter
can ban the president but you know these
courts are claiming it's it's a first
amendment issue
maybe these are not platforms in fact
they're common carriers like phone
companies here's here's what i'm saying
the rules for section 23 for those that
aren't familiar basically say
a a web service platform can't be held
responsible for the things its users say
you've got to sue the user long story
short
if i have a a if if sheamus has a
a blog let's say you set up a blog where
you write articles about religion
and you you have a comment section so
that people can respond to you and give
you thoughts
and you have rules where you're like
this is specifically for talk on
christianity and our opinions it makes
sense in my opinion then
to ban people who violate your rules
because the point of your website is for
you sheamus to publish
not for the comments those are ancillary
those are peripheral to the main
objective
twitter's express purpose is users
commenting and posting things yeah which
is more like a phone company
yes imagine if like you went to verizon
for a phone
not to talk to people but to hear what
the ceo of verizon wanted to tell you
right it's very different you know what
i mean oh but you can't call someone but
every day you open your phone and
there's the ceo talking
and then you can like well i think
you're dumb that's that's more like
what they're trying to claim you know
what i mean it's kind of how these
android phones are
i don't think google doesn't hit me with
an ad every time i open my phone but
there are google ads well that is just
they are just burning money so they
don't do that right
don't don't give away the libertarians
got mad at me though uh oh
no the libertarian party of texas said
it was horrible for free speech
because a company was being the
government was getting in the way this
is the this is the weirdest thing to me
about the
the big al libertarian position on this
why is it that
the big l libertarian party is
pro-authoritarianism unless
as long as it's coming from corporations
it's really very weird isn't it
right so i'm little libertarian meaning
i overwhelmingly just want the
individual to be protected
when a massive multinational corporation
is dumping money into politics
and manipulating the the the ability for
people to speak and get their you know
representatives elected that's
authoritarianism
and i'm not okay with that well yeah it
would be one thing if it was like a
totally
completely free private market then it
would make some sense to be like no they
have to be
protected and we can't break them up but
there's so much state involvement
already
that it seems as if state involvement in
the direction of helping people to
express themselves instead of
allowing the big tech companies to do
whatever they want and be supported in
that decision is probably
more in line with a lot of the
classically liberal principles
libertarians have agree or disagree with
them
you can't break up twitter though
twitter works as a service
because of its ubiquity yeah if you
broke up twitter into like 10 services
nobody would want to use any of these
services because like who would you be
following
unless they were forced into the
fetaverse then it would make sense but
you can't break up google or twitter in
the same way you can break up google
because google has a bunch of different
companies like
google search can't be broken up they
dominate search period nothing you can
do about it
however google you know alphabet also
owns an ad network
add sales they run ads they buy ads
and they've got you know the g suite
they've got calendar they've got all
these things
yeah all of these different areas that
do a bunch of different crazy things you
could break that up
so in terms of of big tech what i see is
the usefulness of social media is in its
monopolistic tendencies not in terms of
abuse of its users but in the fact that
everybody uses one service to
communicate
so that's that's why i'm very much in
favor of it needs to be regulated
there's not going to be twitter too
parlor almost came about it got crushed
yeah so that's that's where it's really
bad it's not about antitrust it's about
what is this rico is a racketeering what
do you call it when all these companies
come together
and they collude to stifle any
competition hostile takeover
no it's just it's trust violations and
stuff like that right
yeah bad stuff hostile takers when you
buy a company out right
yeah those were made illegal in their 19
early 1900s no i think they still happen
what do you mean well they're supposed
to be illegal they buy up as much shares
as possible until they have controlling
majority and then they take it yeah they
ruin the value
which is what those those horrible
redditors did to gamestop it was very
sad
well did you hear that they're going to
be issuing new stock really
they just started over gamestop i think
announced that they had a bump in sales
and they were going to be doing a stock
offering
and then a bunch of people start selling
because a stock offering means
the short sellers have an exit however
the stock still isn't like 200 bucks so
really ah it's a lot of fun it's still
really high right now
yeah i'm surprised it didn't it didn't
take a dive my thoughts on this free
speech thing is that i've never heard of
a corporation
upholding free speech in the in the
history of the world that is what the
united states government was built for
so obviously i think we should rely on
the government for this one
the the government doesn't guarantee
free speech the government is stop
is prohibited from infringing upon free
speech oh okay
so when people this the republic the
libertarian party responded to me on
twitter and they were like you think the
problem will be like it'll be made
better with government involvement
and i'm like the government involvement
goes so far as saying
you can't do that not that they're gonna
show up to the twitter's headquarters
nationalized twitter yeah yeah and then
you send your tweet out and they give
you a tracking number they'll be like
it'll be up in two weeks
right the government is like it's init
your inalienable right is the freedom to
speech now we're going to make sure
people don't infringe on that yeah it's
not it's not about the government
working at twitter
it's about a pathway to a lawsuit it's
about the government saying
you can sue over this that's that's it
and there's also something to be said
for
even if you left the system the way it
was now for the terms of service to
to be applied equitably that's a good
point because there are so many people
who have said things which are
horrifically violent but it's in the
direction of
assaulting conservatives like i mean we
saw this a lot not to beat a dead horse
but hey some dead horses needs their
need their butts kicked this is a pretty
serious topic the whole nick sandman
story is the perfect example you had
like grown adults jumping on this kid no
one has a more punchable face and
we should put them in a wood chipper
just psychotic stuff like that and
they weren't banned yeah but then trump
was like you're my special boys and
you're very peaceful
and they've deleted trump completely off
the planet before screaming at the top
of their lungs you get rid of them
so here's what's gonna happen uh what
could happen with clarence thomas
it doesn't do anything they dismissed
this case they vacated the previous
ruling but
clarence thomas's opinion could be used
in a lawsuit or
as a justification for regulation of
these platforms through congress
i really doubt congress would do
anything because surprise surprise the
left is not in favor of free speech when
it's
their enemies that are being censored so
there's potential
potential for a lawsuit i suppose under
clarence thomas's opinion someone could
now sue and say
here's what clarence thomas said what
would they sue exactly what would they
sue for
so it's it's interesting i've seen a
bunch of arguments and they tend to fail
for for a variety of reasons but when
you sign up for twitter you're entering
into a contract with twitter as well as
tweet is as like you're both in a
contract you're both parties to this
agreement
now twitter and most platforms say we
reserve the right to ban anyone for any
reason
and that basically you know cuts you off
you can't really do much
but the general idea we've seen from
some people is we entered into agreement
and twitter violated that by removing me
for for fake reasons
the other thing however that i think is
being overlooked by people
is that twitter should be sued for
defamation and libel
when someone gets banned so for instance
when milo got suspended
i think they said something like he was
running multiple accounts
okay so they should have said if that's
not true if that's not true
then milo should sue for defamation for
libel saying they issued this statement
to the press it's not true could you
imagine if they started being like we're
going to ban this person for no reason
if that was their public statement but
what if they had to say that or it was
defamation
this person were banning for no reason
what if like they run out of people to
ban
because they've just gotten rid of all
their political opponents but like the
the twitter ceos just they still need
blood
and so they just like start picking
random accounts to be sacrificed every
year
as tribute they just like just some dude
named greg they're just like tweeting
his like is just like he's just like
tweeting
benign stuff and they're like your
account has to go they just like will
randomly grab people and remove them
from the platform
decimation that's a power trip man for
tribal reasons the left has to support
it
yeah and so they all just like eliminate
greg just in unison they're like goodbye
greg
it's like racist we just started
cancelling people
like people fall so in line with the
narrative
that you can't find anyone to cancel so
they just have to randomly select people
for canceling
and like everyone's like wearing their
like cult hoods they're like cancel greg
but it's just you have to clap yeah
exactly no you have to cancel
greg you have to snap snap clapping
remember
clapping yeah yeah you have to do just
flapping them
is a out yeah oh my goodness so i clap
when you clap between words
is that oh that's right but let me tell
you i i have to be honest
that does make me appreciate someone's
opinion more when they have this claps
between it i'm like this guy
he knows something that i don't what
what is the clapping thing and why do
people do it
i don't know i think it's a power grab
like a cool guy thing it's
i'm making noise or they like singing
like i don't know like
when they're being loud like i think
this thing
like you are really like they're going
like i'll be real with you
like they're clapping along to the music
you know what i mean it could be i did i
was guilty of earlier i think when i was
telling people to smash the like button
i was doing a little bit of a clap it
just gets the people going
smash the like button and they do it
because you clap and that means you have
authority
yes clapping mm-hmm yeah clap on click
clap
please clap we could have had you all
that's all we had to do is clap but but
now we don't have jeb bush
seamus yes sir have you been following
the news on project veritas
no i have not i know i've i've been i've
been bad i've been behind i've been
traveling so much lately it's just
sleeping i'm gonna rock this guy i know
i know i really i just haven't been
sleeping is the thing
that's the issue so the story from
project veritas
they uh they stood the new york times
right and they won
a major victory really the case is not
over oh boy
but so so i think james mentioned that
there's only been like in the past
80 years something like eight lawsuits
that have made it past a motion to
dismiss
here's what happens wait eight lawsuits
against the new yorker
okay there's something called anti-slap
strategic lawsuits against public
participation when you sue
a prominent news organization or public
figure you have a it's called an actual
malice standard
meaning you had to have known what you
said was false
or what you wrote was false which is
almost impossible to do very difficult i
think we've talked about this before you
really can't prove that somebody knew
what they were saying
how do you read their mind it's really
difficult to prove intent however in
general
if you can get past a motion to dismiss
you can go through their messages
and you can put them under oath which
veritas now will be able to do
here's the oh boy they didn't clear
their inboxes at the new york times
they've been instructed to preserve all
dating communications it would be did
they smash their cell phones with
hammers and delete every all thirty
thousand emails
you wanna know the best part about this
lawsuit is tell me the defense
the new york times had to get james
o'keefe's lawsuit dismissed
was that their factual news articles are
actually
unverifiable opinions really really so
they said the quiet part loud i love it
yeah it was it was a defense they
basically said when we called project
veritas deceptive
and you know said these things about him
those were just our writers
unverifiable opinions and are thus not
actionable
and the judge said seems to me that if
you're stating something
is a factual news piece but your inter
your reporters interject their opinions
you should be required to tell people it
was an opinion piece
but wait tim if if it's the opposite of
fact news what is that what's that
called opinion
the opposite fate there's another fake
fake word fake
fake some kind of fake news news which
has been
faked what is unbelievable cnn up
i never thought i'd live to see the day
i know this this no this is serious i
mean
project veritas may have if they win and
i think they they will based on this
preliminary ruling it sounds really good
this could set precedent that could last
for 100 years that would be beautiful
yeah i really did not i did not agree
with um
no never mind sorry i was about to make
a comment about the new york times oh
this is new york times or is the cnn
sorry i'm all over the place right now
yeah i didn't agree with new york times
uh you know opinion pieces on the uh
holodomor either
really weird going back along those
opinions yeah yeah those opinion pieces
were pretty bad
that they got pulitzer prizes for for
their opinions
the pulitzer prize and opinion sorry so
the the way the way the news has
typically worked and i've talked to
lawyers about lawsuits as they say tim
i'm sorry they smeared you there's
nothing you can do it's an opinion
and i was like so you mean to tell me if
someone writes an article and says like
ian is you know far right or whatever
they they can publish that in a news
article and just say ian crossland a far
right commenter
even though there's no factual basis to
that and they're like it's their opinion
yeah and i was like hold on if a news
organization is claiming they're
reporting facts
doesn't matter that phrase is an opinion
and i'm like how how is this the way
things work
yeah veritas sues and the judge said
if it's an if it's a fact-based news
story stands to reason
you have to tell people if it's actually
an opinion piece when you put opinions
in it
that changes the whole game yeah so like
if they were to say something which is
objectively verifiable so if they were
to say like sheamus coughlin has an iq
below 85 and i sued well they would win
because that's actually true
but um if they make so i'm curious if
they make objective comments about a
person
beyond far right or far left right
because these terms can be used any way
you want to use
them when what where is the line drawn
with opinion
so if you so for example if you were to
say something like that like this person
is
is is stupid or this per like something
where there's a set standard though or
you like made a comment about someone's
iq but in a disparaging way but that's
something that could actually
be verified would that be opinion or
have you like sort of trespassed into
the area of fact
it's it's actually really crazy what
constitutes opinion and what constitutes
fact
so saying like uh seamus coughlin
did a backflip you know off
off tim's deck to the ground yeah i said
you did something that's a fact
yeah if i said something like seamus
coughlin
cheated at a game of chess that's an
opinion
but hold on a second you can there are
objective standards for whether a person
cheats at chess no
first of all i don't know how to play
right but so you know that i cheated and
so but but so
i shouldn't say necessarily it's an
opinion it's arguable so i went through
this
with with a lawyer over over a really
old piece and it's basically like well
what does cheated mean
define cheated like broke the rules
or changed the rules to benefit himself
or in some way
took an action unbecoming of the
traditional
it's like white supremacist what's
defined white supremacist
uh i would say trump supporter the point
so if you call someone a white
supremacist it's actually
it's a non-actionable opinion really
yeah so i knew that that was true with
labels like extremist i was unaware that
calling someone a white
supremacist is like just a matter i knew
it was oftentimes just used as an
opinion and no one was really using an
objective definition but my
understanding was that's an actual label
here's the issue or like far right dude
i'm so old i remember when you had to be
conservative in order to be considered
far right
crazy right so you uh there there was an
article that came out a while ago i was
talking to a lawyer about it
they called someone a white supremacist
and they said define white supremacists
and i said well the i believe the
academic definition is
an individual who believes the white
race is superior whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's not the academic definition what
the academic definition is about
whiteness and privilege
what yeah that's journalism i mean
that's i'm sorry
that's college universities they say
white supremacy is the structure of
dominant racial hierarchies and society
which could include
asians or whatever and so they change
the definition so if you go into court
and say your honor he called me this and
it's verifiably false
the individual will say no look here's
here's how we define it here's how
everyone believes it
and because the media accepts the
alternate definition opinion
interesting unverifiable and so but and
then of course yeah they're not required
to define their terms
what if i was like sheamus coughlin
whose
cartoons bore millions of people
a month would that be an opinion well
but that's a fact
everybody just watches and they just
have their eyes half closed like their
opinion because
that was that was enough like and then
they'll
hit the like button but if i'm like
sheamus coughlin who's white
who's racial supremacist white skin then
that's a fact or that's awesome no it's
an opinion no if you call me white
supremacist
the statement of fact would be ian
crossland threw a baseball at a baseball
oh and it was either true or false
right but the other ones are this is ian
crossland has a weak [ __ ] arm
is an opinion ian crosslin who has a
weak [ __ ] arm
threw a pathetic pitch at a baseball
game these all sound like happiness
it's just it's crazy that so
i want to avoid getting into getting
into dangerous territory with youtube
because i want to make sure this is a
conversation people can hear
but saying someone did something isn't
always statement of fact which is weird
like like saying ian crossland cheated
at a game of magic the gathering could
be opinion
that's dangerous could be wow so if you
were like you got caught and everyone
saw you sliding cards in your deck or
something
or i could be like i saw him shuffle
that one way and i say
in my expert opinion that was a cheating
move or for instance there's a there's a
move in magic this is a good example
this is a deck game where you shuffle
cards right for those that aren't
familiar
there was something going on where
people would have so
you can shuffle your opponent's deck to
prevent them from cheating you could say
you can cut their deck so pros would
hand their deck to the other player the
other player would shuffle it and hand
it back
there was one thing people would do
where they would shuffle it but then
keep the the last card and throw it on
top of the deck
and they would see the bottom card was
in fact a not good card
then the next turn the player would draw
the bad card and so they said that was
cheating others argued that's not
cheating
you can cut the deck any way you want
information that's revealed because the
card is visible is not
cheating but hold on but you would
actually so but it would only be opinion
if that was what you were referring to
as cheating if you were referring to
something as cheating which is
objectively agreed upon by everyone who
plays the game as being against the
rules then it would be a statement of
fact no
this is where the problem comes in that
apparently opinion or fact has a lot to
do with whether or not large
large enough amounts of people agree
with a certain definition interesting
oh right so if i said you know like
what's something everyone agrees with if
you
a a name you could call somebody that
meant something objective to every
person which is hard to find
ian crossland is a x and everyone's like
oh and x is very clearly this thing
yeah then it would be like well if he's
not then you made that up the problem is
not everyone agrees on what things are
which makes it weird honey is sweet
and that could be a fact but not
everyone's going to taste sweetness when
they taste honey it is
that i think would be a fact because the
high sugar content
there's so many people but think about
people saying things like male and
female don't exist
uh oh right that's i mean that is
objectively not that isn't an
anti-factual statement that's just that
is that's the problem
but of course but yeah i agree that
generally it's it's a matter of
consensus it shouldn't be
so like yes practically speaking i mean
there are facts there are moral truths
which are objective
but we operate in a culture where many
people believe many different things and
so of course
there we don't have this sort of thing
like hegemonic narrative that we might
have surrounding gender that we
did in a time where things made a little
bit more sense with respect to our
sexual politics this is interesting
think about religion it's a really good
really good good context like uh how how
how is the pope defined
like in terms of his position yeah he's
the thinker of christ
so imagine someone who's not religious
would say that's that's fake that's not
true it's not true
so then how could you prove defamation
based on that so he but here is where
you do
get into a matter of fact so if you were
to say like if a non-religious person is
to
to say that like they don't believe the
pope is you know the successor of peter
and christ vicar on earth
that's one thing but then if they were
if they were to say like catholics
do not teach that the pope is christ's
spirit
right now you're talking about something
that like we can the first i i believe
it is a fact that the pope is christ's
vicar on earth
but if we're getting into something that
everyone agrees is factual you just look
at what the church teaches and if you're
saying the church teaches acts when it
objectively teaches why
then you are lying and so this is
something that happened like
joe biden was repeatedly referred to
i've said this before on the show but
he's repeatedly referred to by the media
as a practicing catholic
despite the fact that he actually does
not meet the criteria for what is
considered a practicing catholic based
on the definition that the catholic
church sets because one of the
conditions is you have to give full
ascent to catholic teaching which joe
biden
objectively does not but in the end
that's exactly it that's in the eyes of
a non-catholic he does enough and
they're like oh he seems like he's
practicing they don't even know what the
word practice they don't know what
the word practice and catholic means
exactly but practicing catholic so if
they were to say like
he is a a devout person or a holy man
well those are
those are more subjective but practicing
catholic is a technical term it's not a
subjective label of identity
now what if what if someone said in an
article ian crossland comma
who is objectively factually the
antichrist
comma was seen shopping for a new pair
of jeans today
total opinions yeah well yes it's it's
it's a faith-based thing they can't tell
your lines so then here's the question
though
are you allowed to throw around words
like objectively if you're acknowledging
that you're only speaking an opinion you
are
what it's the weirdest thing like i
would say like ian is objectively a
white supremacist
that's just opinion yes because define
white supremacist
i told you trump voters if you have a
critical race theory definition of white
supremacist
then yes ian is new facts showing that i
think tim's a big jerk
yes well that's that's an opinion
and of course the trade-off
the trade-off that they have to come to
terms with but won't
is that when words become so
subjectively defined they no longer
carry the same weight
so for years and years and years the
word racist was thrown around like it
was nothing
and then probably around the time the
2016 election came around this is not an
original observation other people have
said this
they realize that the word racist just
wasn't cutting it anymore so you'll
notice like it was right around 2017
when they started calling everyone white
supremacist instead
because it's a much more objective
sounding term than racist and also it's
one that can only apply to white people
or people who are in favor of this
structure of whiteness or whatever you
would call it
um and now that seems to have lost all
meaning so i think the next term they've
sort of moved towards
is is incitement to violence right like
oh if you agree with what trump said or
did or you promote his movement that is
incitement towards violence and that's
something they've sort of been doing for
a long
time critical theorists have done this
oh if you disagree with trans ideology
then you are inciting violence against
trans people because hate crimes occur
against them and that's the result of
the fact that you're creating a culture
of hatred etc
but it's such a it's it's so easy to
make that argument for any group of
people
for example i could say well veterans
have a very high suicide rate so you
know criticizing u.s foreign policy
probably makes a lot of them feel
horrible about their experience overseas
so you're contributing to their suicide
rate
you can play these same games with any
group you want so imagine a journalist
emails you
and they're like hey sheamus you want to
just get some some comments from you
real quick about the story we're working
on
delete is what i do just a real quick
question
would you be in favor of you know say
people pooling their resources to try
and improve
technology towards newer cooler energy
tech like fusion
sheamus supports the green new deal and
then they would write done
you're like oh that sounds good then
they would write sheamus coughlin comma
a proponent of the green new deal comma
and you and you would say that's not
true i never supported that like we
asked him in email
if he was in favor of supporting green
new technology said yes
so we call them a proponent of the great
new deal which should be fair that is
the one
left-wing policy i do support the
agreement we can't we can't afford not
to have a green nude deal right now
here's the best part because you just
said that you can never sue someone who
claims you're proponent of the green new
deal even though i'm just hashtag jk
doesn't matter really yeah because that
does not hold up in a court of law
if somebody wrote sheamus coughlin of
freedom tunes who is a proponent of the
green new deal
said today that blah blah if you sued
they would show that clip where you said
it's the one that i actually agree on
and the judge is going to be like i
think a reasonable person can conclude
you were joking
but you can't hold them responsible you
can't expect the media to be reasonable
people so we're going to let them off
the hook here
there's a possibility that they'll say a
reasonable person would have understood
the joke and thus they shouldn't have
but i think actually a reasonable judge
would say you can't just
assume someone understands your intent
that's hilarious if you say something
and someone takes it literally so
everything everyone has ever joked about
really could just be
literal oh yeah and the issue becomes
cultural enforcement as to whether or
not you hold institutions credible based
on what they say something
like what if i'm playing a character in
a movie does
does jeff goldblum actually believe life
will find a way so the issue that says
to the actual male standard
if there's a clip of you and you say
something like the green new deal is the
best
i absolutely am in favor of this and it
turned out to be tim now you can say
about you too oh of course but i but
i i like the the real green new deal not
the aoc green new deal which is a cult
manifesto
so i actually do like the idea of
infrastructure investment and new
technologies
i don't like aoc's version which is some
kind of weird cult manifesto about
equity and healthcare and paying people
who don't want to work
that's garbage nonsense but before the
greenwood
now we're getting well she's the boss
dude she's the boss the point come up
with your own plan until then listen
if someone writes a story about you
saying you support the green new deal
and they see a clip from a movie of you
saying it
you can't prove actual malice because
they'll say look
i realize after the fact he doesn't but
at the time i genuinely thought it was
true based on
what if you kill someone in a movie and
they say a known murderer
we're actually not that far from that
happening though is the problem
what about um actual malice standard oh
come on something's wrong they knew that
i know
so you could have just gotten the clip
so i'm sure i'm sure there are some
lawyers who might have
like listen this is this is mostly just
based off my experience i'm not a lawyer
my understanding is
the challenge is proving actual malice
meaning
if ian says sheamus did something
sheamus has to prove
ian knew beforehand what he was saying
was false if someone says
here's the clip we saw of sheamus
shooting a rocket launcher into a
building full of nuns
then people would be like well a
reasonable person might get
that didn't happen well hold on but can
we now say tim poole
who falsely accused sheamus of shooting
a rocket launcher under a group of nuns
he calls himself a journalist and he
spread the fake news kid so what about
ed norton can we say that he is a white
supremacist
you call anyone white's premise i guess
but could you call him a neo-nazi is
neo-nazi and actually an actually
defined term
neo-nazi it's opinion what if you say
like curb stomp somebody killed them
because he did it in a movie
i think you chose to portray
or what if you don't what do you have to
say transformation here's malice listen
listen here's what it ultimately comes
down to
whether or not the judge thinks you're
being reasonable or absurd
the problem is with times v sullivan you
have an actual malice standard which
means
knowing that what you're saying is false
that's a really
hard thing to prove yes extremely
difficult so the new york times fought
project veritas
in a ridiculous way saying our
fact-based news
it was actually unverifiable opinion and
thus is is not actionable
and the judge was like yo this is this
is not an opinion section
so what you're saying is taken as fact
by most people it doesn't matter
this is this is the importance of the
veritas ruling they're basically saying
your opinions are purported as facts
because the new york times
therefore you lose the protections of
you know that
of the opinion standard wow okay but the
nyt
of course is saying actually we
are as a matter of fact opinion
journalists no that was their defense
and then the judge responded the new
york times responded that their
fact-based news article about veritas
was actually unverifiable opinion ooh
and the judge then said okay while
typically
opinions you can't sue for someone's
opinion you put them in a fact-based
news article
if i say so this is where it gets
interesting this
article is 100 fact ian crossland
is a lying thief yeah then they can be
like that's actually your opinion
if i said this is my opinion ian crosson
is a lying thief then they can't sue me
and if you do a fact-based article with
99
facts and then one opinion the entire
article becomes an opinion
if so this is why veritas is so
important
because in the past when i've talked
about libel suits every lawyer says
it's an opinion you can't sue and i'm
like they straight up accuse me of doing
a thing
no it's an opinion orphans but you can't
define some of these terms like
causing hurt or violence or incitement
all of these things are interpretable
so you can't win with this new ruling
changes the game
veritas open the door so here's a
question what if you're so you mentioned
that the article can be 99
fact based and if it's one like snopes
would sign off on all of it
but if there's one part which is opinion
now the whole thing is an opinion piece
but
has to be labeled opinion but okay but
what if the opinion is really like what
if you're listing facts
and then at the end you're like yes this
did happen there was this scandal with
the biden administration blah blah and
then at the end you're like i
enjoy grapes they taste good and it's an
obvious opinion
or like if at some point article
something comes up which is your opinion
but isn't quite related maybe you're
setting up the story
but everything else is fact-paced now
the whole thing is an opinion piece and
i can say whatever i want
fascinating hold on you can't say things
you know to be false are my cartoons
opinion
or did those happen i don't know dude
you make a good point because i'm pretty
tired right now just like movies
what was joe biden what was your latest
one joe biden joe biden stutter please
check that out if you're watching
so i don't know if you guys know this
but joe biden it's not that his brain
isn't functioning well and he's not fit
to be the leader of the free world
he actually has a stutter because that's
how stuttering works yeah
so i did a video on joe biden's speech
therapy class i think you guys are
really going to enjoy it he gets the
stutter worked out it's
it's it's just uh gut busting laugh fest
yeah
yes laugh fest from start to end i did a
video of him in math class as well
you know i think i think the funniest
thing to like
in terms of biden is talking about
putting the razor blade in the barrel
that's good
dude that is the best it's tim and i
have a bit that we're we
i don't want to spoil it but we have
we're probably going to do a freedom
tune based on
another one basically the idea was too
good
i don't know before the show we were
talking about biden and
as we always do i can opini my opinion
is
it was a good idea thank you hey you
made a great point about
movies and how if an actor does
something in a movie it doesn't mean
that they did it in real life
because this is a tv show whether you
wanna i don't know if people realize or
not we're on tv right now doing
characters on a show
this is not how i am when we sit around
a table i want dinner i want to stretch
elevated versions of ourselves we have a
correction so is all social media okay
we have a correction real quick
zero just super chatted i'm wrong actual
malice is quote with knowledge that it
was false or with reckless disregard of
whether it was false or not
so if it was a movie clip of someone
doing something it would be reckless
disregard but that was just your opinion
when you said that malice is the
standard so really
you're not wrong it's just your opinion
exactly it was my expert opinion
i did not actually know it wasn't true
so it's not actually my point is this is
a tv show we've entered a new stage of
art creation where social media is an
art form
we're becoming heightened artistic
characters that we're creating
and we're projecting so how can you
prove any of this stuff is really who we
are what we say on social media
ian's not real actually of jack's
imagination yeah he's an astral
projection
yes i have come here to warn you be good
to each other
now is the time we're fractals of the
greater whole
i love it there you go beautiful um okay
so i'm wondering interesting how can you
is that a fact let's get snopes in here
are we are we fragile of the greater
whole i would say no i'll see what snope
says
it's the hollow fractal graphic universe
i would love to help to fact check
is ian crossland from timcast irl
projection of jacksonville partly true
partly true yeah although he is from the
outer verse
and has inhabited the body he does have
a physical form in this room
i don't know actually verified that he
has physical form
no no they're they i'm in contact with
them
okay about that i wonder if we'll be
able to prove that anyone that did
anything on social media was not a
character they created there they
weren't doing a bit
well my whole twitter is a bit at this
point but that's my youtube channel
basically was
i mean i believed a lot of it but i said
it in a crazy character way
that is an age-old defense though like i
was just kidding and sometimes people
abuse that like you weren't kidding
but also it's hard to know because
sometimes you'll make a really obvious
joke
people like can you believe he said that
like i was joking and they're like
dude you're falling back and it was just
a joke come on i just don't care anymore
i tweeted i tweeted today is 4 5
which will now be known as trump day in
honor of the 45th president
like a thousand retweets yeah it will be
that is literally a joke
i just thought it was funny because i
was doing i do the dates for what i'm
making playlist and i'm like oh it's
it's four or five forty seven fourty
four it's trump day
four and i'm like i'm tweeting that
people were like
a lot of people were just laughing like
but there and then i i tweeted welcome
to twitter enjoy your stay here
so it's it's just they're these people i
i mentioned the hooping thing
when jack bosobic posted the clip of
george floyd saying who was hooping i
responded with the urban dictionary
entry for what hooping is saying get
your hoop and don't forget to get your
hooping mug it's a joke the whole thing
was a joke
because urban dictionary says it's you
know shoving stuff up your bum gross but
it says at the bottom get your hoopin
mug
on urban dictionary and then these
people were like
tim you know this is why people think
the wright is so racist because you know
they say things like this or whatever
and someone was like
tim claims he's from the hood but he
doesn't know what hoopin means and i'm
like no it's a joke you
you're like you're the kind of people
who thought my impeach the queen tweet
was real
right this is what so i don't even care
what's up what are you gonna do
yeah reckless disregard the truth at
this point
we have a faction of people who are so
unable to empathize and understand humor
how could the reckless disregard
standard even hold yeah
so i know these fellas um at this
publication called
the babylon b and they're very you know
like
they're handsome but they're very slow
and i try to explain things to them and
no i'm they're both great actually but
um i'm not sure if you guys have heard
but snope says has fact checked them in
the past that's been a really big
problem then what happens is
they're demoted in the algorithm because
they're considered to be fake news even
though it's obvious satire
and people i did a video on this a while
ago but they had this really bogus study
where they said that some large
percentage of conservatives
believed that babylon b headlines were
factual but the way they arrived at that
number
is they took babylon b headlines removed
them from the context of being published
by a satirical outlet and reworded them
in a way to make them sound like they
were
serious so there was one headline and it
was something like
the evidence against russiagate was put
there to test our faith it was like
obvious joke right and it's a character
of the creationist argument that uh
fossils are put there to test our faith
and
they reworded it to be like this
media pundit said that his faith in
russiagate is unshakable and no evidence
could change his mind
it's like okay well you've totally
changed it so this that's where it gets
really dangerous with fact checking and
and the fact that people get a lot of
leniency
who actual journalists will get this
leniency that
comedians and satirists on the right
won't get
right yeah like the the articles in
question would say something like
it you know it was like aoc stands atop
her desk and proclaims her
her proclaims her support for communism
too much fanfare
then flags dropped down and the russian
the soviet anthem plays
yeah and then they would reword it to be
like aoc announces that she's she's
forming the communist party
and it's like people are like oh wow
that sounds like real news like she's
joining like she's
and then but it was like the actual
context was absurdity they were they
stripped out the absurdity to make it
factual news that could be real like
sheamus sheamus coughlin goes for a walk
with the dog when the actual article was
sheamus coughlin walks world's giant dog
you know a big red dog
and it's really false and this is funny
so i was actually just going to pull up
um
i wrote this it's been probably about
two years but
it's been probably been about two years
so i was pulling up the script on my
google drive so i can pull some of the
examples up but
just to verify that um it was just
friendly ribbing i i just got a
an email from ethan so we don't actually
hate each other as i was checking no no
i love those guys
um great articles they are so basically
they reworded yeah so the article it was
yeah
cnn god allowed the mueller report to
test our unshakeable faith in collusion
was rewarded as cnn anchor anderson
cooper said his belief that trump
colluded with russia is unshakable it
will not change regardless of statements
or evidence to the contrary
like that actually sounds yeah like it
sounds like something something
exactly um and and so they published
this whole study about how people are
buying into fake news is if it's fact
despite the fact that this is
obvious satire and basically everyone
knows it and so yeah
it's it's extremely upsetting and it's
totally one-sided because it never
happens the other way i mean again even
actual publications like
well let's not call new york times an
actual publication but people who
purport to be telling the truth in a
fact-based manner are given this
leniency
or they are at least attempting to get
the kind of leniency that satire
websites on the right don't get
i would say at this point based on the
ruling from this judge that it is a fact
that the new york times
injects opinions and masquerades as a
factual
the new york times masquerade is a
fact-based news outlet when in fact
it's publishing opinion pieces under the
guys effect so there's this guy i don't
know if you guys know him his it's like
michael ballis michael malus michael
michaels i think
that might be friends he's he has said
some things
my life he has which suggests he's kind
of doesn't like
the new york times or uh anything should
have been better
yeah so i would just look into what he's
written about this stuff because he
seems
like this guy this guy's saying he
doesn't think nyt is that great so i
would just
shout out to michael too much oh my god
yeah
michael that's why i tried to say his
name wrong i was like i can't keep
he was on the show last thursday yeah he
was you know he was great
yeah yeah we just we literally like
shout him out like three times a week
he's very funny and also a writer his
new book will be coming out soon
there you go now i get another shout out
now michael mouse all right all right
let's go to super chats we love you
michael
super chats uh let's see so as as per
usual the uh youtube
oh we got the tinfoil gorilla oh yeah
yeah did you guys see it in the in the
it's it's in the chats pinned i finally
put up the tinfoil gorilla thing
it's the it's the tinfoil gorilla shirt
he's a gorilla it's got black tacks out
of white tax and he's wearing the
tinfoil hat
and um it's only me up for a little
while so this is a limited edition
we're going to do the tin foil because
basically i decided we were wondering
whether we would do the tinfoil hat i
was like ah let's just do the regular
gorilla
so we have the graphic and then i
mentioned and i was like we'll put it up
at some point then i never did and then
i finally did
so it's there now you can buy it and it
will probably not be up for longer than
like a week or two just because i figure
this won't be special
so he's able to reflect electromagnetic
frequency
off of his head and protect his brain
no no because electromagnetic waves can
actually go through your body
and up your skull oh and then what it
does is it actually makes it bounce
around
more evolution yeah people don't realize
that it actually creates a dome that
like a satellite dish it captures the
waves i like it
so anyway let's read some super chats we
got one but people were thinking about
your beanie then just by the way that's
right i can't read the name because
youtube is blocking it but they say
can't wait for you and b tatum only two
i joined membership with
that's gonna be a lot of fun with
brandon tatum yeah i don't know
your mom says who would win the fist
fight joe biden or bill clinton
seamus that's a tough one i mean bill's
bill's younger right good deal
i think yeah who is older i think i
think i think bill
clinton age let's see if i get a fact or
an opinion bill clinton's 74
and joe biden 78. joe but yeah i guess
joe biden is older
bill clinton would would would bop him
one and win because he's got four years
up yeah i think that i think but it's
hard because the last time i saw a
picture of
bill clinton he looked like neither of
these men are in good shape
i'm not sure i don't i don't think uh
the victory would exactly be
impressive but i think that joe
biden would probably lose i don't think
joe well here's the thing
so joe we know that joe knows how to
street fight right like he has a razor
he puts it in a rain barrel bangs
another cement gets it rusty
rusty yep brings it i'm going to wrap
this chain around your head right
and bill wright would be helping him um
but
but bill clinton is younger and has i
think a little bit more energy
and also he he's survived being married
to hillary clinton so i just
i don't think it's a nasty yeah i think
that he's uh i think he's
probably got the edge here biden's got
the reach that's true
he's got those long arms yeah yeah yeah
but
bill's probably got some crazy kamasutra
typhoo or something he's ready to tangle
yeah
he's been doing it like let me show you
how i do it bill i mean i mean
joe let's go let's get into the fight
yeah i think um yeah now
of course this is uh this is factual and
not opinion based so you can call me at
the no
all right all right let's see logan
cisco says irl crew crowder made me
think last week why is the left saying
only cops need guns but also a cab
also portnoy pool 2024. i like that
ticket i don't know about that one
dave's cool though but uh i'm not
running for office
um yeah because there's no logic there's
only tribalism
they don't listen if you're like the
people here i believe all operate on
principles
where it's like i don't care about who
you know which tribe it is i care about
whether it's right or wrong and will
like you know make things better
and then you have some people who are
just like i want to win and i'm trying
to be on the side of the winner
so they're simultaneously like only the
cops should have guns
only the social workers should have guns
too that's right yeah
it's basically cops that's the social
worker thing is so funny because you
would just end up creating a two-tier
system which would in practice end up
being way more racist
because the phone calls the social
workers would probably be more likely to
happen in neighborhoods where you have
like these cairns calling the police on
everyone and they'd send social workers
out
so it would be it would be areas where
there's less violent crime getting a lot
of the social workers and you'd create
sort of like a two-tier system where
impoverished neighborhoods
were policed by actual cops in like
wealthier neighborhoods and white
neighborhoods just got these cushy
social workers
have you done a cartoon on the social
workers responding to crimes i have not
that seems like something that might be
something that might be fun you know
there's like there's like a city burning
down in a violent fire and there's like
a criminal it's holding people hostage
[Laughter]
all right fish b8 for you says
yeah yes sheamus i love freedom tunes
you did a binge watch on the debunkers
earlier today thank you thank you keep
watching this we're going to be
producing more we had to hiccup with the
production of one that i was hoping to
release this month but we might get it
out later they've been
they've been a lot of fun and i enjoy
making them so thank you so much
quiet guitarist fan says should make a
shirt with ian that says you could make
that out of graphene
also correction from friday christ was
crucified on friday and died on friday
that's true that's correct yes yeah good
friend oh wow good friend you can make a
lot of stuff out of graphene that's true
yeah
ian's made out of graphene yes it might
not be wrong
we are carbon actually all right chris
blank production says we'll be posting
your segments from your other channels
on your website soon
uh they're there already at the bottom
you scroll down and the other segments
are actually there so it's the last
guy's chat so jesus was crucified and
died within the same day i thought he
hung there for days no no he died so it
was common for people who were victims
of crucifixion to hang there for days
but but jesus did not he died
they were like well they were
particularly
they stabbed him after he was dead but
they were particularly brutal to him
in a way that they generally were not to
people who they crucified so part of the
punishment was true
with crucifixion is that you would hang
there and you would just have like your
like face pecked off by by crows and you
yeah
it was horrible and but no he he died uh
quickly because of how harsh and brutal
they were to him and he gave up his
spirit and then they
went and stabbed him through also one
thing they would do to wrap their
to speed the crucifixion up which they
didn't do to jesus but did to the two
thieves on the cross next to him is they
would break the legs too so that they
would just go down and then suffocate
because when you're crucified you have
to prop yourself
up to get oxygen into your lungs and so
you will die of asphyxiation
once you get weak enough to just hang
there which is you know
that's going beyond the unbelievably
excruciating pain you're in and
yeah they would just come up and crack
the people's legs if they wanted to
speed the process up so they couldn't
prop themselves up and get air this
prophesied exactly they wouldn't break
any bones but they did pierce him
through his heart and yeah water and
blood came out
all right let's see uh
zuav bro says tim i'm a cop things have
gone gone crazy and the environment
working is very hostile towards us the
george floyd trial will only cause more
problems for us all
yeah man i don't like that yeah support
support policing in general we need it
but it of course you know it's a big
conversation all right all the gaming
channel says hey man
same say say man stop hating on bible
man that's my guy
it took me this long to say this because
i'm never able to catch the stream
stop hating on bible man was that a show
do you know bible
cartoon oh my goodness i never
saw it but i've seen little bits and
pieces this was like the wait was bible
man was this live action or was this
animated
this is animated right so this is the
90s it was a 3d thing yes i'm from
i never saw any of it but i i definitely
all right
cicantia says okay here's 50 from ali
now read it
how about leo youtubers law enforcement
officer youtubers like donut operator
officer 401 angry cops or mike the cop
and experience pov for leo and some good
input on cops
among all this elio tension would uh and
misconception
is as an excellent idea i'm familiar
with donut operator i'm not familiar
with the others
but uh i'd love it what's up how about
brandon tatum i know yeah for sure
i think i think donut operator be cool
too i've seen his videos yeah yeah i've
seen some other stuff i think mike the
cop isn't a cop anymore though right but
he's still a law enforcement youtuber is
it yeah
aren't they all i think so are they all
retired yeah i didn't imagine i mean who
would want to do that job anymore
i just like donut operator it's a great
name that is a great fantastic name
very self-aware name yep having fun with
it troy
dunham says hey sheamus love your
channel what is your take on the media
blackout of the april 2nd insurrection
on the capitol
oh i'm not familiar the media was so
blacked out that i didn't even
get a word on it i'm glad you i'm glad
you support my my work and appreciate it
that was the farrakhan guys
yeah also a supporter of louis farrakhan
that's weird why would the media talk
about that
the insurrection isn't that a threat to
our democracy we are
very dangerous to our democracy yeah all
right crimson says you guys are awesome
thanks for helping me get to know the
lies and truth spread by media
if the other people like me want to talk
uh if the other people
like me want to talk political and
culture i have a twitch at crimson 27
where i like to talk about ideas uh
normal on around normally on around 11
p.m
central time hey there you go nice aces
maven says glad to see sheamus on the
show again
they really enjoy freedom tunes maybe
you can look into kvon comedy as a
possible future guest
we'll check it out find someone please
just done with me through with me yeah
same breath he's like like now sheamus
is great but let me tell you about this
other guy
hey fat freddy's cat says tim check out
the opening of the new skate park in des
moines iowa do tour will be there
it would be a cool thing if you were
there and i work too much
so that won't happen that's cool though
holograms
holograms astro projections simple
holograms
all right jerk emperor says i don't know
how much more negatively i can handle
uh negatively i can handle i'm horrible
because i'm male
oppressed because i'm black and now i
just outright suck because
i'm a trevor i didn't pick that name
guys
sounds like timcats.com is auntie trevor
i'm sorry somebody super chatted saying
trevor sucks it's just like as a general
and so we started joking like trevor's
the worst dude i like trevor hold on i
like trump
you know i do too trevor's trump was
great trevor
yeah who said trevor was bad what
they're being why would you do this is
trevor cast irl
so you're all about it males and people
that identify as black people like those
people are awesome yeah people are
awesome especially trevor's
agreed all right all right jack dawe
says i would like to file a complaint
over our pillow
the quality was too high i thought i
bought the one-off teespring as a gag
for a friend come to find out it's
decent what the hell
i thought i was buying burlap and
peanuts here's the thing what keeps you
up isn't the pillow it's the emptiness
in your stomach under communism
the teespring version was just the joke
of graphic and then i decided to make
the burlap sack with packing peanuts
which we're gonna have to figure that
one out how to get it out uh the idea
was to have to do something with ryan
long where we would make this commercial
but i think i don't i don't know if the
good pillow from david hogg is actually
going to happen
i don't think it is and we need it to
because the burlap
is on standby we do have them we do have
have you seen the our pillow
i saw one it was actually in the room
that i am uh crashing
oh yeah so right there i was very
offended i got ready
it's got the fist holding the pillow yes
let's see zechariah kitzman says cop
here most policies are open-ended to
leave liability on the officer and not
the department i.e if a school shooting
happens the department can't mandate i
go in
because if i'm in if i'm injured it's on
them oh wow and then the cop gets sued
for not
going in yeah and then amazing
all right let's see where we're at ryan
m prower says
just got out of the military but a week
before i did we went through that
extremism training
i don't have enough room to summarize it
here but it was unnerving
how the brief went and what the message
was i just wanted to let
and then it cuts off right there they
found him they found
they're like stop typing that you're
coming back
can't they make you re-enlist what yeah
like if you're in for four years and you
leave they can reactivate you and force
you to come back
i don't know how that works pretty sure
that's true i think i've heard of that
yeah i'm pretty sure
i mean they can draft people they
haven't done in a long time but i guess
it wouldn't
completely shock me they could pull
people back in i think it depends on
your skill set
nicholas montiel says last week a super
chat said john the baptist wrote the
book of revelation
it was written by the apostle john when
he was in exile
on patmos love you all stoicism episode
yes
ryan holiday yes do you know who wrote
revelation john
was not the baptist it was a different
john john of atmos is that what his name
was
patmos patmos no no it's apostle john
when he was an excellent
yeah and that's not the baptist no it's
a different one okay
jameis do you think that the vaccine
passport is the mark of the beast
like marjorie taylor green here's the
thing
um the mark of the beast like
low church protestants as a group not
always
i love them if they're being super good
people i love them
but often we'll just kind of call
anything the mark of the beast so
basically everything that comes out um
the babylon b
also had a very funny article is like
the vaccine passport can now be like
uh like they're now offering the vaccine
passport like on your hand or forehead
i don't know i mean people there are so
many things that people have said are
the mark of the beast i just tend to say
no no what do you think is the mark of
the beast
super chat believe it or not i don't
think that's the
end of times i think that's it's a
typical view people take everyone sort
of thinks their generation is the last
one yeah i don't think so
also like scripture says no one knows
the day nor the hour
and it's very well possible that this is
the the
end of the west as we know it or the end
of america
but it's it's not the end times there
hasn't been worldwide apostasy there's
been quite a lot of apostasy in the west
but in in africa and even in china the
church is growing
yeah kiwi 2113 says love it when ian
brings up
dune it is my ultimate favorite series
it's an interesting look behind the
curtain of government in space it was
so good i read it when i worked at
ground zero i would do 6 p.m to 6 a.m
shifts thursday friday sat friday
saturday sunday
and i had a lot of time on my hands
doing security and man
that book kept my attention eve welcome
says ian you're adorable if i wasn't
happily married
dot dot wing eve well fellow you
shouldn't really be talking about
people that way if you are happily
married please don't uh
she says fellow dune nerds unite or if
you're on
what does that mean i think that's from
dude i don't know i read it yeah she
said i don't know i read it
by the way i was not insinuating that
she's not happily married just please
don't
even if you're unhappily man say
emotionally unfaithful things
talbot link says you all need to read
machiavelli's art of war
very info dense two-part conversation
that discusses a great many structures
and behaviors
can work as a short play it'll blow
ian's mind mock you i didn't know
machiavelli did an art of war
i saw you have art of war on your desk
downstairs yeah great i think that might
be my little art someone knows
me too i think someone gave them tiffany
tim's favorite book he's always plugging
it he's always telling me read art of
work
have you read it through it yet no um
have you ever heard that story about
that chinese general
who was completely outnumbered and had
very little resources
so he opened the gates to his fortress
climbed on top of the wall and started
playing a lute
yeah yeah and then when the enemy's army
shut up they were like he's it's a trap
retreat
he's one of my heroes he was lubey's uh
he's known he like invented the
risky man the the crossbow the repeating
cross was going to do yeah no
it's risky but a lot of people would not
do that yeah it smelled like zoo
g-league
he's one of my idols historical idols
that guy he's known as like a
genius genius strategist philosopher
he was a farmer that retired from public
life and did not want to join and they
sought him out and had to go visit him
three they called him the sleeping
dragon the people were like you gotta
find this guy and he went he kept
appealing to him like please join me and
he was like and then he realized i have
to i have no choice i'm being called to
service that story is great you'll love
that guy they thought it was a trap
yeah a genius killdog says hey tim ian
is right the entire seven book dune
series is amazing truly great
storytelling
that's right i only read the first one
benjamin says remember when youtube had
five stars out of likes and dislikes
and i'm fighting a sneeze right now oh
bless you i'm not gonna sneeze i have
some tissues for you tim
you can breathe out your mouth really
slow so i
today i am taking over i am standing in
for tim who has to sneeze right now
normally i can fight it but the sneeze
got me that's good
so are you here's the thing i learned
this recently i thought that
everybody sneezed more easily when they
were staring at light i know like
staring into a light can induce sneezes
for me yeah but for apparently that's
not true for everybody interesting
people with light eyes wow yeah okay so
tim does like staring into the light
help you sneeze
yeah you have to sneeze okay i have a
theory about that so
when you have like bacteria or fungus in
your wind canal
um and you stare in the light the light
kills it and then your body expels it
i don't think that's true i don't think
that sounds more i think it just
stimulates it sounds like a new york
times opinion piece
yeah opinion by the way all right
uh i can't read cyrillic so i'll just
read what they said e
says dune is awesome sci-fi tv series is
a bit better than lynch's movie
especially second installation children
of dune that follows later books
it shows that paul the protagonist of
the first book is not a hero of the
story but a villain
wow dude did you guys see this new story
from the new york times
about the mario this opinion piece the
the original mario brothers found
in a desk for after 35 years so 35 years
ago
somebody bought an original mario
brothers nes and left it in their drawer
and forgot about it for 35 years okay
whoa
they got busy they sold it for i think
like six hundred and sixty thousand
dollars
oh in the box yeah the best part though
sealed shrink wrap and everything the
best part was how the new york times had
to explain what the game was
and they say according to the
instruction booklet
it is a game about two brothers mario
and luigi who are attempting to rescue
princess toadstool
after bowser and his turtle army invaded
the mushroom kingdom turning the people
into bricks
i didn't know that happened yeah and so
mario's fake news that's more
nyt misleading check this out mario's
literally literally going around
punching batteries shattering them and
then ripping the things up from their
innards like
so so there's mushroom people turned
into bricks
and mario punches them shattering them
to pieces and then the mushroom remnants
come out and he eats it to grow
that's crazy i didn't realize that that
was the plot wow is true
this sounds like opinion most people
don't know that mario punches bricks
yeah his little hand is up his hand is
up
i should just punch super mario brothers
mario brothers was where mario and luigi
were in like
on one screen and the things keep coming
out of the sides that's a fun game
that's in my
in mario 3. i love that yeah yeah the
arcade version yeah
super mario did you guys ever play
donkey kong oh boy i hope you bring down
where you jump up with a spray gun and
you're spraying donkey kong's butt and
he's like climbing up
towards beehives and like he's knocking
bees down at you i don't know
it's so funny i i think i might i i
mostly remember the original donkey kong
dude that game was awesome
you're jumping over junior was amazing
too
yeah really good i used to dream about
that game oh my goodness yeah like how
can i make that
jump to that other rope did you yeah
remember like back in the day
dude so we so we had a sega genesis like
every time you died you had to
completely restart i remember as a kid
like having dreams where i finally got
to the next level and i'd be like what
what happens there so we got a couple
different super chats from people so
i'll just read one of them about
enlistment uh enlistment carl reed says
my first super chat
when you enlist you have an eight year
commitment to the government you sign up
for four
you have four years active in four years
inactive ready reserves oh
eight years i i can't remember who i
asked but i was like
i think on the show would you recommend
enlisting or going to the account like
going to college and getting a degree in
like get your degree
first you know going in as like an
officer
yeah wait they want you to get your but
so can't you only take advantage of the
gi bill
like does the gi bill pay off your loans
after you have them or no idea
i don't know but i guess the difference
is being enlisted or being a
commissioned officer
better going up as an officer
interesting daniel bundrick says the
ironic thing about the knee being on
floyd's shoulder blade is that it would
suppress
breathing more than it were if it were
on his neck since no pressure is on the
lungs especially in the case of fentanyl
overdose where respiratory suppression
is common
interesting yeah very very interesting
bitcoin hunter says great show freedom
tunes is awesome oh thank you
agree with that thank you yeah yeah i
hope
and that's not opinion no i'm beating
that horse everyone's just saying dune
over and over again
isn't it i was going to say this earlier
it's hilarious like what people will
seize on from a show you never know you
discuss so many topics but
you never know what's going to stick
dude i know underrated in our society i
think that's why
dune is uh dune is awful
super chat tell me why i'm wrong yeah i
knew it i knew it yes
i knew you were going to do this yes tim
tim
i'm kidding i'm kidding i don't know
paula tradies
and duke conan zazuba says
oligopoly is the word you're looking for
to describe big tech and social media
i definitely like the idea of making
twitter a common carrier
yeah yeah how do you do that if it's a
public a private company
i think it's a private company here's
the thing i think instead of twitter
everyone in the country
should just get one big like group text
and when you have your training
you'll just like send your opinion out
to the group text and everyone else gets
it
it would just be going but like if you
find something really cool you just like
retweet it you know what i mean
or you like resend it and that's it i
think twitter should be should be
everyone should be banned from twitter
and trump should be brought back trump
is
only one allowed on twitter that's
hilarious
he would love it it's just called
trumper and like there's no react
ability because no one has an account
but he's still just tweeting all the
time now you can only
everyone love this i do no i think it'd
be even funnier if you couldn't even do
that so he has no feedback on the tweets
but he's just still
constantly putting them out there he's
doing that with his emails
so like he's just sending he sends like
150 character emails out every time he
would have sent a tweet out no nizan's
paragraphs you see what he said
i was kidding you see what he said the
other day where he's like you know
happy easter to everybody even the crazy
radical left that's trying to destroy
the country or whatever oh my gosh
do you think he does voice to text dude
i don't know i'll punch it in with you i
think it is a voice to text i feel like
he does a lot holding his phone up he's
going
happy easter to all the crazy to uh
tap to all of the crazy just like tim
does to all of them
dude is that who's he talking the way
because he kind of talks like someone
who's doing text-to-speech like the way
he enunciates it so he's like
the reason for this thing is like it is
kind of how you talk when you're trying
to make sure the smartphone gets you
right you're talking to a secretary
okay he's perk he has like he has the
perfect cadence for text to speak or
speech to text
holy cow i just noticed that
boot booster pack booster back says tim
it's 1971.
you're the proud owner of the first ever
federal reserve note you borrowed at two
percent interest
but if you are the sole owner of the
note how do you pay back the two percent
interest
well borrow more of course that's the
way the system works welcome to the
ponzi scheme
yeah well you guys are too cynical you
guys are too cynical federal reserve is
great our monetary policy is perfect
uh-huh let's stop it now boys so frito
says are you going to make timcast.com
an app
yes what so the first thing is the new
and improved website people are never
happy
and then we're going to make an app
where you should be able to play things
with
the phone off like you you can turn it
on press play
yeah it's not you i don't think you can
do it with the website unless you have
like a browser or something i don't know
if we can do it through a website
but you should be able to do it with the
app once we get the app going and
exciting
you know look the website was was i
don't want to say it was delayed a
little bit we were optimistic but we
decided to
be less optimistic in terms of launch
because
we have to make sure all the members
poured over properly and then nobody
gets
an issue with login assume that when
something's getting developed it's going
to take
three times longer three to four times
longer than you expect
i know that's a little extreme but
that's good yeah with with modern tech
if you're
you're up against these big guys uh
three to four times longer
is this is this true someone get a
calculator howdy hey says when you
divide
when you divide 2020 by 666 oh i'm not
doing this i don't care what it is
this is the mark of the abuse three you
guessed it three zero three three zero
oh bro three oh is that true
yes you do i just did it i just did it
that bruises it three out three three
out
of ten three oh three three oh that's
joe biden's text number oh
inductive when you divide 20 but like
our commenter i'm sorry i wrote you off
three three oh three three oh
six six six oh man all right let's do a
couple more
20 20. garhent says the new dune movie
is woke so get ready for the last jedi
all over again
i can see paul saying the sand worm
suffered oppression
and we are on the sand worms lands oh
i hope he's joking are you joking it
doesn't come out till october
oh no stephen clyde says sheamus what
when are you going to do another
collaboration with eric julia that's a
good question i love working with eric
every time i need a voice i hit him up
so he's really busy so sometimes it's
hard to get a hold of him but he's
usually pretty cool about doing things
uh when we're able to sync up
yeah i would love to just because the
thing is like he and i when we
collaborate it's never like this planned
thing where we're like we need to collab
on something it's usually i'm just like
i have a cartoon which i would like a
voice for eric can you do this voice
because he always does a fantastic job i
mean he hits it out of the park so yeah
eric he's he's really funny
he's really funny his delivery is
fantastic every time
the the racism explain video i remember
i wrote that script and i was like happy
with the script
but then i was looking back and i was
like ah maybe it's not that great but
when i got his audio for it i was like
this
is so funny like his delivery just makes
it
every time i've ever had him do a voice
he's just crushed it so yeah i want to
use him
as often as possible but he's just he's
too good for me now
no i'm kidding i don't even i don't even
want fake beef i love i love eric
he's doing really well and good for him
he should be yeah
no we we we'll we'll do something again
soon i'll hit him up right now oh snap
erica let's collab this real-time
inspiration
all right let's just do uh we'll do one
more alexander
scrippety says in my department we were
trained to put the leg knee across
one shoulder blade on a downward angle
so not to damage the spine at the neck
very interesting that makes a lot of
sense yeah well ladies and gentlemen
smash that like button if you haven't
already and i guess a thousand likes or
i delete my channel uh
well you you said ultimatum has been 15
no 15. oh we're good we're at 16 000 so
sheamus coughlin who supports the green
new deal and said give
fifteen thousand likes or i will delete
my channel sixteen thousand likes we did
it baby
freedom tunes is staying on the internet
that's right
thank you all thank you thank you guys
so much but wait there's more there's
gonna be an exclusive members only
segment coming
up in just about an hour so over at
timcast.com so go to timcast.com become
a member
and learn about all the spicy hot takes
from sheamus that he can't see on
youtube that i can't say on youtube i'm
too scared
i'm gonna grill him about religion god
jesus
jesuits oh man i'm not getting there
because i want to know it all
we actually did that a really long
segment with james before so listen
you can see it's like an hour long we
did like an hour didn't we yeah we did
it was a good it was a very interesting
yeah
um but we'll have something else coming
up and that'll that'll be for members at
timcast.com so sign up to help out
and make sure you smash the like button
subscribe to this channel
we are so close to 1 million subscribers
and with your support sharing this and
being like yo subscribe
we will break one million subscribers
and uh so do it this show is live
wednesday friday at 8 pm so come back
the next time if you're listening on
itunes and spotify give us that good
review and you can follow me on all
social media platforms at tim cast
my other channels are youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comteamcastnews and
sheamus i think you have a youtube
channel i do have a youtube channel
youtube.com
freedom tunes go find freedom tunes i
love it i love making the cartoons there
they're a lot of fun
i also have a second channel that i run
with the foundation for economic
education called common sense soapbox
with sheamus coughlin we usually get
into economic issues but those are just
short little educational cartoons a lot
of fun
very informative so check those places
out um youtube.com are we gonna do what
are we gonna do
that bit from earlier we were talking
about oh we're 100 tim and i are gonna
make a freedom tuesday
tim and i are gonna make a freedom tunes
together and also guess what ladies and
gentlemen tim
just told me with his eyes that from now
on i am on every episode because i got
us to 16k
likes i'm so proud of all of you as
viewers
we're gonna do sheamus cast irl is the
new name of the show do you think you're
sneaking on the show because we got the
extra chair you can have it join us bro
let's talk about it love is real yeah
yeah love is kind
yeah he's got an actual chair luke luke
abandoned us yeah luke
one day he was just like i'm gonna i'm
gonna go i'll be right back
he like he like he went to go to the
bathroom and then you're like where's
where do we go he said he had to go get
a pack of cigarettes
yeah yeah and then we never saw him he
just left thank you for a pack of smokes
he's gone i'm looking forward to luke
luke's return i don't think that's gonna
happen
you better come back here luke that's
right he's like i'm just gonna go to the
store real quick with all of my stuff
tomorrow
hey guys he's got luke stuff to do you
know i wanted to just to shout out my
my website iancrossline.net i'm just
kidding uh i want to
thank you guys for being a part of this
movement this show and this opportunity
we have a million
million subscribers millions of people
we're gonna get involved with this we're
gonna get a bunch of gold plaques for
everybody that's so amazing what an
opportunity to help people and like
spread
information that can help people so
thank you guys for being part of it and
thanks tim for having me and lydia
we're gonna get we're gonna get rings
made
if they allow me a gold plaque for
everybody who who helps work on the show
love it uh that's a lot you've heard it
i got us i got a 16 000 likes i get a
gold plaque
from tim right now i'm gonna make one
out of styrofoam with like a knife and
just some some cheap paint to give it to
sheamus let's um spray paint
check out youtube.com freedom tunes
right now everybody go there hit the
like button let's get to
17 000 likes on my videos
if every single one of my videos doesn't
get to 17 000 likes
i am never doing tim cast again as a
matter of opinion
and he's i will never do tim cast again
i love it and then i love it there's me
in the corner i am all
similarly excited about reaching a
million i think i've been the most
excited because i've been worrying about
this since christmas
i was like this is all i want for
christmas is a million subscribers we
didn't hit that
goal it's coming up soon easter time
whatever the next holiday is
anyway i'm sour patch lids on twitter
and mines and real sour patches on gab
and instagram
people are saying luke is in the chat we
need to give him a special flair
he's watching the show and he's and he's
he's like hey hey go to we are
change.org is it yeah but he abandoned
his responsibilities so he doesn't
show okay luke the best political
t-shirts dot com is that yeah
yeah yeah well all right ladies and
gentlemen we're gonna have a bonus
segment up in about an hour at
timcast.com so go there
check it out we'll see you all then bye
guys
you